Pock, Teams da wieder mal Sound verstellt, immer der gleiche Scheiße, jeden Tag, ob Microsoft
das mal irgendwann noch hinkriegt, dass man das Teams verbieten kann, das nervt mich unglaublich,
so wunderbar, exzellent, jetzt hört sich das gleich schon viel besser an, viel weniger
übersteuert, so muss das sein. Ja, soll ich mal was erzählen, ich habe heute Mittag,
ich weiß ja noch keiner da, warte schon mal kurz. So Leute, also, ich habe heute noch
ein Video gemacht, ich bin jetzt nicht ready für Happy Yoshi Musik, das geht nicht, keine
Chance. Ja, vielleicht hat es Twitch beziehungsweise Discord oder wer auch immer, dass man irgendwann
kapiert, dass der Stream online ist und hat die Notification rausgeschickt, mir schickt
gerade jemand To Do Benachrichtigungen für morgen im Teams, 19 Uhr, manche Leute sind
auch rund um die Uhr aktiv irgendwie. F, ja, also ich erzähle euch mal, ich wollte
heute Mittag die Daten von der Festplatte kopieren auf mein Netzlaufwerk, also aufs
Netz und ich bin auf die Idee gekommen, weil die Festplatte irgendwie immer länger gebraucht
hat um anzugehen, ganz merkwürdig, die ging an, also ich habe hier einen externen USB
Link dran, überhaupt kein Problem, die ging an, aber die hat gefühlt immer länger gebraucht
zum angehen, ich habe das ehrlich gesagt aber auch ein bisschen auf diesen Festplattenwechselrahmen
geschoben und heute Mittag hatte ich eine Runde, hatte ich eine Besprechung und im Hintergrund
hat das Ding aufs Netzlaufwerk kopiert, auf einmal macht es klack und die Festplatte
geht aus und wieder an, habe ich mir nichts bei gedacht, habe ich mir gedacht, das liegt
am, wie gesagt liegt am Festplattenwechselrahmen, der abkackt, aber nachdem es klack gemacht
hat, hat Windows die Festplatte nicht mehr erkannt. Ja, und ich habe es dann unter Linux
dran gehängt, habe geguckt, also Partitions-Tabelle und so ist noch drauf und ich kann hier aber
nicht mal mounten, keine Chance, so und ich dachte mir, also was ich schon ausprobiert
habe, ich habe die mal ohne diesen Festplattenwechsel, also ich habe ja so einen USB-Dock für die
Festplatte, mal direkt an SATA angeschlossen, bringt auch nichts, das ist eine, wen das interessiert
ist, eine Seagate Iron Wolf 10TB, nass optimiert, eher kaputt optimiert würde ich sagen, Hetzner
hatte ich gehackt für Preischamp, das wird es sein, genau, Hetzner will die Rechte am
Preischamp, heute haben mir schon die ersten Leute geschrieben, dass sie Preischamp was
gefunden haben, richtig nice und falls wir das mit der Festplatte jetzt wieder, oh Leute,
ich wollte euch nicht planten, sorry, Preischamp, falls wir das heute mit, wow, bisschen groß
vielleicht, falls wir das mit der Festplatte schnell hinkriegen sollen oder sich schnell
raus stellt, dass es überhaupt nicht funktioniert, dann machen wir heute noch ein bisschen an
Preischamp weiter, ich wollte nämlich einen Analytics noch einbauen, dass ich sehe, wer
darauf zugreift, dass ich Unique User sehe, dass ich sehe wie viele Leute das benutzen,
also aber nur, wenn wir das schnell hinkriegen, genau, das Teil habe ich, das sieht von vorne,
das ist nicht die schwarze, das ist die hier, die weiße Festplatte, oje, darf man das überhaupt
noch sagen, 2021, mein Black and Wild List ist ja auch so ein No Go Wort, das ist aber
eine schwarze und eine weiße Festplatte, na ob da nicht irgendwas dahinter steckt, Anzeige
ist raus, triggert, Stripes 007, ich sehe gerade, dass du am Start bist, ist der Captain
Peng auch da, Leute, falls ihr den Captain Peng seht, falls ihr im Laufe des Streams
den Captain Peng seht, dann sagt mal Bescheid, aber Stripes 007 möchtest du Mod werden,
jetzt hat bestimmt AFK oder sowas, weil ich habe festgestellt, wir brauchen noch 1-2 Mods
und ich habe mich mit den anderen Admins mal ein wenig besprochen und die haben ein paar
Leute genannt und ich habe mir ein paar rausgesucht, du bist am Handy unterwegs, das macht nichts,
gebt dir mal Mod, wenn das nicht funktioniert ist auch nicht so wild, du kannst ja auch
am Handy Leute timeouten und sonst was, es geht nur darum, wie gesagt, es ist ja hier
nicht so viel, man muss ja nicht wirklich viel machen, wir kommen auch die ganzen Streams
mal aus, wenn kein Mod da ist, aber ab und zu sind doch mal ein paar nervige Leute da
und wenn ich gerade konzentriert bin, dann kriege ich das manchmal nicht mit und die
nerven da drum, so wenn ihr Captain Peng seht nachher, sagt Bescheid, der kriegt nämlich
auch Mod, exellent, also das ist die Festplatte, die ist kaputt, jetzt habe ich euch die Story
erzählt, warum die Festplatte RIP ist und jetzt probieren wir mal aus, ob wir das Ganze
hinkriegen, ich habe übrigens als USB, USB Chakun XT oder so heißt das Ding, so übelst,
ja genau das Teil hier, übelster Crap, so wie gesagt, da war die Festplatte Mittag
drin und beim Kopieren, lustigerweise beim Kopieren aufs Netzlaufwerk, ich hatte schon,
ich hatte schon quasi so die Eingebung, die Festplatte geht demnächst kaputt, beim Kopieren,
aber noch ganz am Anfang vom Kopieren, hat es Klick gemacht, die Festplatte ist ausgegangen,
Festplatte wieder angegangen, danach konnte ich es nicht mehr lesen, ich weiß nicht woran
das liegt, es könnte auch sein, dass die Festplatte gar keinen Schaden hat, der dieser Doc aber
scheiße ist oder gewackelt hat oder was auch immer und deswegen jetzt das NTFS kaputt ist
oder irgendwas, man weiß ja bei Windows nie, so ich habe glaube ich Subs übersehen, Roffel
1436, neun Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub, hier Massive IQ Increase wieder für den Chat,
soll ich euch mal was sagen, Twitch Statistik, was meint ihr, was die Durchschnittszuschauer
Anzahl im Dezember war, es gibt jetzt keinen Sub zu gewinnen, wobei, ohne Scheiß, wer es
errät, kriegt echt ein Statistik, ich muss jetzt mal gucken ob ich es finde, viele sind
gar nicht so schlecht, ganz knapp, ganz knapp, ok Leute, vorbei ist, vorbei ist, also korrekt
wäre 253, was extrem geil ist, das Jahr davor waren es keine Ahnung noch 150 oder so, also
Massive, 153, ne ne ne ne, ihr seid zu spät, aber außer jemand hat to kill schon 252 gesagt
vorhin, aber das lasse ich trotzdem mal gelten, hat dann vorher noch einer gesagt, nein, 252,
ah 254 hast du vorhin gesagt, ok, dann hast du trotzdem gewonnen, hard to kill, gibt es
einmal exquisite Subscription, du kannst jetzt auch die paar Emotes verwenden, die wir haben,
meine acht Emotes mit 28 Emotes, ich glaube in Wirklichkeit bei den anderen Leuten ist
das so, die haben immer quasi schon mehr Emotes als die Emote Slots haben und ich habe 28
Emote Slots oder habe 8 Emotes drin, ihr wisst, ich bin bei sowas nicht so schnell, dafür
muss man sagen, die Emotes die jetzt drin sind, sind Pock, ich habe gestern einen YouTube
Account entdeckt, fand die Videos die ich gesehen habe, nice, ach meinen, ich habe gerade
gelesen, ich habe gestern einen YouTube Kanal entdeckt, fand die Videos nice, da habe ich
gedacht, ja, soll vorkommen, auf YouTube gibt es auch für Einzelne noch nice, ja, das ist
natürlich extra nice, exquisite nice, das ist quasi, so, der Festplatten Kontrolle
hat ein Firmware, echt, ernsthaft, ok, wo hast du das, was, ok, das ist das, wir machen
erstmal die VM an, wie lange hat der Kekwe noch den Weihnachtshut drauf, bis ich das
raus mache und ich finde das mit dem Weihnachtshut ehrlich gesagt ziemlich nice, weil mittlerweile
haben die anderen schon alle den Weihnachtshut wieder weg, ich glaube ich lasse den Weihnachtshut,
das ist Big Brain Taktik, wir lassen den Weihnachtshut das ganze Jahr und dann nächstes Jahr Weihnachten
machen wir den Weihnachtshut weg und es checkt dann keiner, dann machen sie alle, dann brain
laggen sie alle, ich habe eine, ich war eine Empfehlung unter Kommandas Krieger, Krieger
Video, das muss ja schon ewig her sein, so, also, also was, iWolf HD Controller Bug, ernsthaft,
der Iron Wolf, das wie die Red Nass Festplatten Problem, aha, Controller Update, da gibt es
ein Update zu, ernsthaft, ich habe noch nie eine Festplatte geupdatet Leute, muss man,
ich wusste noch nicht mal, dass man eine Festplatte überhaupt updaten muss, ah, das ist really
bad, Samsung Magician kann ich ja schlecht Seagate Sachen abdehnen, du hast was gegoogelt,
schick mal einen Link, schick mal einen Link, die Festplatte einmal geklickt und danach
hat sie Windows nicht mehr erkannt, ich glaube aber, dass nur NTFS kaputt ist, weil, Copy
Link Address, kann man das rein machen, ja, ok, Fixed, mit ZFS, aha, wow, das Ding ist
ja ziemlich im Arsch, und wie updatet man das jetzt, ja, ja, das sieht tatsächlich
ähnlich aus, zu dem was ich vorhin hatte, nee, nee, das war was anderes, Firmware, es
gibt eine neue Firmware, wo, wo, wo gibt es die zum Download, what the, ok, Seagate Firmware
Download, alter, die Seiten sind immer so unübersichtlich, Firmware Update Utility Instructions, ok,
das probieren wir nachher, also, was wir jetzt machen Leute, ich schließe die jetzt mal
an und ich zeige euch unter Linux, dass die prinzipiell noch da ist, ja, die Festplatte,
also, Moment, wo habe ich, ich muss erstmal Strom rein machen, die geht auch noch an,
ist alles in Ordnung, die macht auch keine komischen Geräusche, also ich vermute ja,
das ist folgendes, der Festplattenwechsel Rahmen, der hat kurz rumgespackt, was auch
noch, vielleicht, vielleicht von der Stromleiste oder so, die Festplatte ging ganz kurz Strom
an und aus und hat irgendwie das Fallsystem dabei kaputt gemacht, weil es Windows Crap
ist, gibt es auch Updates für Klinkenpunkte, eh, mittlerweile, mittlerweile, eh, wahrscheinlich
schon, ja, what the, hier da ist es, SDB, guck, der erkennt noch Partition, der erkennt
noch Partition und der erkennt auch, das habe ich vorhin schon, der erkennt auch, dass das
prinzipiell die richtige Größe ist und alles, so, ich zeige euch aber mal, wie es in Windows
aussieht, ich zeige es euch mal, wie es in Windows aussieht, also, wenn wir mal hier
Explorer auf, ah, so sieht es normalerweise aus und ich detatche das Ding mal von der VM
und jetzt sollte Windows das normalerweise erkennen, ja, und so sieht es dann aus, Windows
sagt jetzt, man kann das formatieren, ich will das natürlich nicht formatieren und
was auch sehr merkwürdig ist, wenn ich in die Eigenschaften gehe, was auch schon mal
ganz komisch ist, ja, Chat, wir müssen jetzt nicht Backseat, eh, ich weiß gar nicht, wie
ich es nennen soll, Backseat Festplatten Rescue machen, weil, wenn jetzt 50 Leute, 50 Nachrichten
schreiben, ich kann das gar nicht alles machen, ja, Backseat Rescue, so, das ist auch, das
ist auch sehr merkwürdig, dass das Ding als Null Byte angezeigt wird, so, und dann habe
ich auch schon mal in, äh, äh, warte mal, Disk, wie hieß der Kram, Disk Util oder Disk
Manager, oder wie hieß denn der Kram denn, ey, Alter, Windows, come on, Disk, ist das
nicht, nicht Disk Manager, Disk, was, Disk MGR, tja, anscheinend nicht, keck weh, Storage,
ah, was, Disk, MGMT, ah, kann das sein, dass man das nur ausführen darf, wenn man root
ist, ah, ok, dann, ah, nein, fuck, keck, wait, fast, fast, ok, jetzt, jetzt, wie, wie
geht das unter Windows, wie starte ich sowas, was ich nicht finde, als Admin, kann, ah,
ich hab ne Idee, ich starte einfach ne CMD als Admin, exellent, und dann führ ich's
aus, Disk, MGMT, alles klar, perfekt, oh, was jetzt, Postchamp, Postchamp, Cap'n Peng,
ist mittlerweile da, weiß nicht, hab ja noch nix gesehen von ihm, ja, stimmt, stimmt, theoretisch
müsste er da sein, so, ok, also hier haben wir ganz viel Gedöns am Start, und die Disk
ist der Meinung, sie ist raw, also ich vermute mal, dass schlicht und ergreifend in irgendeiner
Art und Weise Partition gefickt ist, oder so, keine Ahnung, jaja, sie baut, treibst
nicht, ehm, also, und ich mach jetzt aber da auch in Windows nix, weil wenn ich in Windows
da jetzt was mach, ist es auf jeden Fall kaputt, deswegen, ich attach das, ich attach das nochmal
in die Nux, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob wir das irgendwie recovered kriegen, ehm, ich muss
eben mal gucken, dass ich das richtige attache, exellent, exellent, na, der erkennt das ja
auch alles, wunderbar, ich zeig euch übrigens was passiert, wenn ich das vers... oh, ich
hab mich schon, ich hab mich grad geschockt, ich hab gedacht, auf einmal ist es ein X4,
hab ich gedacht, wie soll denn das gehen, so, das passt mal auf, wenn ich's versuch, wenn
ich's versuch, das zu mounte, eh, Checkdisk geht übrigens auch nicht, Sebaro, Checkdisk
sagt, Windows kann auf das Laufwerk nicht zugreifen, so, wenn ich's versuch zu mounten, dann geht
das nicht, und zwar mit so einem ganz, ganz kryptischen, kryptischen Fehler, eh, NTFS
most post fix blub blub blub, also, das NTFS ist irgendwie kaputt, interpretier ich da
jetzt mal rein, so, das heißt, die Festplatte ist irgendwie im Arsch, probier mal Testdisk,
das wollte ich lustigerweise jetzt gleich ausbringen, das hab ich mir nämlich im Internet
auch schon ausgesucht, was ich aber mal nebenbei machen will, ehm, ich hab nämlich die doofe
Vermutung, dass ich noch Windows Tools installieren muss, weil ich mit Linux nichts gebacken bekommt,
achso, übrigens, was auch nicht geht, ist NTFS fix, geht auch nicht, das hab ich schon
ausprobiert, keck wait, vorhin ging das nicht, ah, jetzt, jetzt ist er abgekackt, ok, jaja,
jetzt geht's nicht, also NTFS fix hab ich auch schon ausprobiert, so, jaja, Testdisk
probier mal gleich aus, das hab ich nämlich vorhin auch schon im Internet gesehen, so,
und wenn das mit Testdisk nicht funktioniert, ich hab keinen Bock, mir irgendwelche komischen
Festplatten Rescue Tools für Windows auf mein System hier zu installieren, ich werd
meine VM installieren und den Kram dort dann bestelzen, ja, übrigens, ich zeig euch doch
mal den besten Hack überhaupt, Download Windows 10 ISO, da kommt man ja bei Microsoft auf
die Seite, das kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich, so, und jetzt passt mal auf, passt mal auf,
Big Brain, Massive Big Brain Trick, ihr geht einfach hier auf Inspect und stellt die Seite
auf Mobile und Reloaded und auf einmal könnt ihr den ISO runterladen, ist das nicht geiler
Hackermantrick, offizielles ISO von Microsoft kannst du runterladen, das geht aber nur wenn
du so tust, als bist du von einem Mobile Gerät unterwegs, ja, die Seite unter Linux Browsen,
das kann ja jeder, aber das ist die Hackermant-Variante, ja, aber die Variante ist viel geiler als
alle anderen, müsst ihr schon zugeben, die hat so richtig was Secret-mäßiges, so, jetzt
lädt er den Kram runter und bevor ich teste und das Zeug starte, ich mach ne Windows 10
Installation, wobei, bis es runtergeladen ist, können wir das machen, ich wollte nämlich
ne Windows 10 Installation im Hintergrund anmachen, dass wir dann komische Windows Rettungstools
ausprobieren können, wo ich kein Bock hab, mein System damit zu versauen, so, ok und
jetzt installieren wir Test-Disc, das hab ich nämlich vorhin im Internet auch schon
gelesen, aber das ist glaube ich so ein richtiges Hackermant-Tool, wo man auch im Zweifelsfall
die Festplatte mit kaputt machen kann und by the way, bevor ihr mal sowas probiert, macht
es nicht so wie ich, nehmt die Festplatte und macht als erstes mal nen Dampf von, aber
ich hab keinen Bock in den 10TB Dampf zu machen, weil da sitze ich erstmal den ganzen Tag da,
bis das gemacht ist, deswegen mach ich jetzt einfach live und wenn es nicht geht, ist die
Festplatte kaputt.
R-Studio, ich guck mal, es ist NTFS, es ist Windows-Laufwerk, da hab ich mein, übrigens,
es ist nicht so extrem wichtig, was da drauf ist, da hab ich meine ganzen Battlefield-Gameplays
drauf, das wär halt ein bisschen scheiße, wenn ich die verlier, weil dann hab ich keine,
da hab ich keine Battlefield-Gameplays mehr, das heißt wirklich so, getDataBack, das klingt
schon nach Scam, getDataBack von Heise, oh, das sieht ja aus wie von 1980, funktioniert
das?
Na gut, das Zeug ist so alt, das funktioniert, 82 Euro, what the fuck, so wie NTFS, ok, wir
gucken erstmal, ob das Unterledungs funktioniert, so, was macht der Download, ich schmeiß die
Installation schon mal an, weil, wenn das mit Disc Setup hier nicht funktioniert, dann
brauchen wir, wir brauchen ein frisches Windows, ich installiere mir diese ominösen Rettungstools
nicht auf meinem Haus, das kannst du vergessen, es ist Windows, es ist nicht Windows XP, es
ist Windows 10 x64, wir wollen das erstellen auf E, das geht ja witzigerweise, übrigens
ist es wieder ein Punkt dafür, nur noch SSDs, Alter, rescue, nur noch SSDs, ganze Magnetplatten-Schiss,
mit der SSD wäre das nicht passiert, die SSD hätte einfach funktioniert, die SSD braucht
natürlich das Netzteil und nix, einfach crap, das ist richtig crapware, ja, 40096, wunderbar,
Nat, Eis, nvm, eh emuliert das Ding jetzt, ernsthaft, ok, so, und den Drucker raus machen,
wer weiß nicht, warum da überhaupt immer noch standardmäßig ein Drucker drin ist,
so, jetzt mach ich die Install an und dann probieren wir, dann probieren wir das mit,
mit Test-Disc, ob wir irgendwas rekaffern können, was interne, was, wie, wo, meine Festplatte,
nix interne Festplatte, richtig echte Festplatte, also so richtig Hardware, keine VM, wenn die
VM kaputt ist, das wäre ja easy, warum dauert der Download so lang, ja, weil es 6 GB groß
ist, und Microsoft wahrscheinlich nicht so spendabel mit Bandbreite ist, übrigens Leute,
der Preis-Champ, wisst ihr was der Preis-Champ für CPU-Auslastung hat, guckt euch das mal
an, das sieht seit gestern Abend, wo wir auf 16 Cores abgecreated haben, so aus, der Preis-Champ
ist permanent auf 10 CPU Cores ausgelastet, und hat seit gestern glaube 100 Gigabit, ne,
doch, ne, 90, keine Ahnung, ich guck mal, wir gucken mal schnell, der Preis-Champ hat
seit gestern, 6,3 Gigabyte gesendet und 100 Gigabyte, ne, 10, warte, ich bin verwirrt,
100 Gigabyte sind es, oder, 100 Gigabyte, 100 Gigabyte empfangen, was das surft, das
surft den Preis-Champ, ähm, ups, Moment, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken, was ist,
was ist das, der Awesome-Tech-Stack-Analyse, guck mal hier, ich bin richtig modern, alter,
seht ihr das, alter, alter, bin ich geiler Web-Entwickler, dass du das nicht Remote laufen
lässt, was, was, was, was Remote, hä, Leute, ihr müsst die Chat-Nachrichten schon so schreiben,
dass ich die verstehen kann, also, exzellent, guck mal hier, wir haben Vue.js, wir haben
Vue.tify, wir haben Webpack, ja gut, das ist standardmäßig so, ich benutze die Google
Font-RP, das war mir selber gar nicht bewusst, und ich benutze JS-Deliver, alles klar, exzellent,
exzellent, so, ähm, das da wird da gehostet, der tracked die Verfügbarkeit von Hardware
und updated immer live, wenn er irgendwo was gefunden hat, und was halt viel Rechenleistung
braucht, sind die Crawler, guck hier, PC King jetzt, äh, und wenn man da oben drauf
drückt, kommt man direkt auf der Seite raus, ähm, kann sich für den Schlapper von 2000
Euro eine Grafikkarte kaufen, ok, also kann ich jetzt die Windows-Installation starten,
ist der Download jetzt endlich fertig, jawoll, äh, wo ist es denn, Harddisk, ne, da, ISO,
Download, International, ok, jetzt, ABAP würde, im Prinzip, es ist ja alles, die das nicht
direkten Assembler programmieren, Kackenhubs, da sind wir uns doch einig, warum sollte man
überhaupt mit Cobol, ABAP und sonst was anfangen, wenn man das auch in Assembler machen kann,
oder noch besser, direkt in Hex, einfach direkt in Hex, äh, lässt du den Crawler durch Proxies
laufen, nicht dass sie die IP sperren, wenn die die IP sperren, ändere ich einfach die
IP und ändere den DNS, aber ich, ich könnte, ich könnte wirklich, ähm, das über irgendwelche
Proxies laufen lassen, ach, keine Ahnung, so, das kann jetzt im Hintergrund installieren,
Windows 10 braucht ja nicht so viel, richtige Hackers machen nur 01, ist ja in Hex, in Hex
ist ja, ist ja im Prinzip nur 01, ist ja binary, also byteweise, so, hier, Professional brauchen
wir bestimmt, wir brauchen Pro Education, äh, Pro, BAM, gut, Windows, dann installieren
wir, und dann probieren wir Test Disk aus, alles klar, so, Windows installiert im Hintergrund,
jetzt testen wir das mal, also, äh, der Preis-Champ down, Preis-Champ ist noch da,
ok, was auch immer, das russische Botnetz ist wieder am Start, ok, also, Test Disk,
hab ich noch nie gemacht, wie, wie verwendet man den Kram, also, es geht um, ich muss noch
mal gucken, welche Festplatte, dev-sdb, woops, sdb ist die, die kaputt ist, dev-sdb hat
zwei, hat, hat eine EFI-Partition oder irgendwie so, eine GPT, GPT-Partition, GPT-Disk, ok,
also, was mal, Test Disk, äh, oh, was, ich mach mal kurz, exellent, Leute, wir sind,
wir können schlecht lesen, ne, so, also, was wollen die, create a new log file, ach so,
dass man mit, dass man das recovern kann, ok, create, sdb, ich hab kein, Leute, ich hab
legit keine Ahnung, was ich da mach, what the, proceed, ah, jetzt muss ich auswählen,
was das Ding für ne, Partitionstabelle mal hatte, also sag ich GPT, ok, ah ja, guck
mal, da sagt er auch, GPT heißt bin detected, ich mach mal ein bisschen kleiner, das hältst
ja echt nicht aus, zu groß, so, der sagt, GPT ist detected, ok, also, nehmen wir GPT
und jetzt, advanced geometry options, Analyse, Analyse, guck mal, da erkennt es doch auch,
ms data, von da bis da, ok, was auch immer, oh, die Musik, also, das ist einfach gut
jetzt, und jetzt, quick search, oder backup, ok, save current partition list to backup,
ok, backup ist immer gut, der macht jetzt aber keinen dump oder sowas, ne, und jetzt,
oh, ne, ne, das glaub ich keine gute Idee, warte mal, quick search, enter, und jetzt,
list files, guck mal, Leute, hier unten, list files, mal gucken, ob der was erkennt, ne,
natürlich nicht, das wär jetzt auch zu einfach gewesen, wenn die files jetzt einfach da
werden, das wär ja zu einfach gewesen, ok, der chat sagt, ich soll nach advanced gehen,
komm ich jetzt irgendwie auch wieder zurück, komm ich jetzt wieder zurück, continue, quit,
ok, ich soll advanced gehen, und dann, das da, image creation, ne, image will ich nicht,
10 terabyte image dauert ja ewig, list, list and copy files, he he, ist kein files da, keck
wait, ich glaube ja, meine gameplay sind weg, wenn ich ehrlich bin, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, kann man da jetzt noch was anderes machen, und delete, no, das ist nicht gut, oder, weil
testes kam ich auch, das war auch eines der ersten Sachen, die ich gefunden habe im internet,
dass das geht, gab es nicht ein windows update, das ntfs kaputt macht, ne, ne, damit hat das
nichts zu tun, ja, modify options, dump, ich hab keine Ahnung, was, no, ok, ok, ok, ok,
jaar, analysen, weil er meckert ja auch, das ist irgendwie nicht aligned ist, oder so,
p-fuck, ist nicht kaputt gegangen, ich hab von dieser Sache schon die weiße voraussicht
auf das Netzlaufwerk, und ganz am Anfang, vom kopieren auf dasisancebeginn, ist die
Festplatte kurz ausgegangen und wieder an, und danach konnte man Windows nicht mehr benutzen,
Tja
Ist Testdisk
von den Typen, die auch
Fotorekt gemacht, was weiß ich
Okay, das funktioniert
Jemand noch glorreiche Ideen, was man mit dem Programm noch ausprobieren
könnte?
Also das funktioniert schonmal nicht
Was mich ja persönlich, ah, ich hab eine Idee, wisst ihr was wir
ausprobieren können? Wir können ausprobieren, ob die Platte
prinzipiell noch lesbar ist
Nee, Deeper Search muss ich nicht
machen, weil die Partition
findet er doch schon
Ich hab eine Idee, was wir machen können, guck mal
Wir machen jetzt
Wir geben jetzt einfach mal
aus, was auf der Festplatte ist
Guck mal, die ist noch
lesbar
Guck mal Leute, die ist noch lesbar
Die Festplatte, ich meine
da kommt da Crap raus, weil's Bytes sind
Aber, äh, also
Guck, Hexdarm
von der Festplatte funktioniert
Äh, minus C für Ascii
Nee, äh, war das minus A
Doch, minus Groß C war's
Guck mal, man kann das Hexdampen
Also die Festplatte
funktioniert prinzipiell noch
Die
Wir können auch mal was ausprobieren
Wir können mal gucken, wie schnell man die noch lesen kann
Was? Kein PV drauf?
Ach so, ja
PV
Äh, wir uns
Okay, wie installiert man PV unter
Arch?
Ja
Pack mal minus SPV
wahrscheinlich, ja
Easy
Okay, wie schnell liest
er den Kram? Okay, das geht
Also, die Festplatte geht noch
Captain Peng, da bist du ja
Da bist du ja, ich hab schon auf dich
gewartet
Jetzt wird er sich wahrscheinlich denken, what, warum?
Forced Champ
Ja, und zwar
Ich hab mich mit den anderen Admins
auf dem Discord beraten, so was
Sie für Vorschläge
haben, welche Leute noch Mod
infrage kommen, weil ich hab mir gedacht
wir brauchen noch so eins, zwei, drei Leute
wenn mal keiner da ist
Und aus der Liste hab ich mir ein paar Leute rausgesucht
und da bin ich unter anderem auf dich
gekommen. Jetzt ist nur die Preisfrage
Willst du Mod werden?
Weil, du weißt, ich sollte mal aufhören die Festplatte
auszulesen, weil wenn die aber abkacken ist, ist
Auslesen, äh, auch richtig
fehlend. Na dann, easy Mod, easy
Life, Captain Peng
Zack, schon ist er
Mod, Poggers
So, das war alles weggebandt, genau
Ok Leute, also Unterdienungsweise
weiß ich jetzt nicht weiter, aber was wir machen können
Wir haben jetzt ja
unser Windows installiert, wir können ein paar
sinnlose Windows Recovery Tools ausprobieren
Wenn alle scheitern
musst du Photorec nehmen
Da gehen die ganzen Dateistrukturen verloren, vieles wird nur
Ne, das ist Müll
Let's start
Region, yes. Jetzt kommt gleich
Hi, I'm Cortana
Deswegen, ach ne, das gibt's nicht mehr, oder?
Cortana ist ja
Cortana ist ja mittlerweile out
Nein, nein, das ist nicht das richtige
Keyboard layout, das ist richtig. By the way
Warum kann ich da nicht einfach G drücken und springen
zu German? Kann mir irgend einer erklären
wer bei Microsoft gedacht hat, das ist
gute Usability hier, das Scheiß
Skip
Nimm dir
Recuva
Was für ein Ding
Das heißt ernsthaft, ernsthaft, das heißt so
Re
Kuva
Kostenlos, ich will
kostenpflichtig kostenlos, exellent
Alter, warum sieht
jetzt mal ohne Mist, Leute, warum sieht diese Software
alles so nach Scam aus?
Das sieht aus wie Software
mit
Ask.com Toolbar
und sich Malware drin
Ach so, das ist kostenpflichtig
kostenlos, ja, was ist es denn jetzt?
Ab, ab, ja, wie Cacquade
Ok, Leute, wir testen mal die Demo
Wir probieren das mal aus
Recuva.com
Alles klar
Das testen wir jetzt, nachdem Windows mich endlich
den Kram hat installieren lassen
Testen wir gleich, Recuva
Übrigens, das
ist ja auch so eine Gängelung von Microsoft
hier, die wollen unbedingt, dass du dir
eine Microsoft Account erstellst, da musst
du hier unten erstmal in der Ecke
auf, ähm, mit
Checkdesk können wir gleich probieren, Sebaro
Offline Account
Und dann muss man sagen, oh ja, ich hab's
verstanden, ich will eine Limited
Experience und jetzt darf ich, ich mein
da muss ich mal überlegen, es geht darum
dass ich mich lokal mit einem Username
und Passwort an meinem PC anmelden kann
Warum ist das so kompliziert, das sollte die
Fall sein
Nee, nee, das geht, das ging glaube ich schon
immer so, ich glaube in Home geht's
glaube ich noch gar nicht, oder?
Ok, äh, Qt Chat
Also ich schreib
mir jetzt auf, Recuva testen wir und vorher
mal Checkdesk, was da
Sebaro gesagt hat, also
Passwort 123456, jawoll
123456, sehr gut
Oh, ich will einfach nur
Patname, eins
da, zwei
und drei
Exzellent
Äh, Don't use
Accept, No Accept, No
Accept
No Accept, No Accept
No Accept, No
Accept
Nein
Das ist ja eine Gängelung hoch 10
mittlerweile der Crap ey, das kann
nicht in den Ernst sein
Leute, ich geh mir mal ganz schnell, während das
Mal schnell was zu fliegen, warte mal kurz
So
Ich war schneller
als die Windows Installation
Auf
Windows
This may take several minutes
Normalerweise dauert das keine Ahnung, 50 Sekunde
oder so, dann ist das fertig
Was das war
Ich war dringend geholt
Leave everything to us
Ja, das hat schon einen kleinen Beigeschmack
mittlerweile, Microsoft
macht ja auch mehr als sie sollen
Browse web with Edge
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal
Warum haben die eigentlich immer noch kein Vmware Tools standardmäßig
drauf? Vm
Install Tools, Yes
In der Zwischenzeit
hatten wir Windows XP schon 5 Mal installiert
Habt ihr könnt euch noch dran erinnern, wie schnell das ging
Das ist, das Windows XP ist
ist geflutscht
By the way, 4 zu 3 ist auch nicht schlecht
mit Windows, da kann man irgend so einen Plötzchen hier neben einplanen
So
Warum ist die Standardauflösung eigentlich
immer noch 4 zu 3?
Wer hat sich das eigentlich
ausgedacht?
So
Fullscreen, excellent
Ok, und jetzt können wir die USB-Geräte
mounten, würde ich sagen
zack, finish
Restart, ja, komm
meinetwegen
Also, Quickport
USB, connect
Achso, ist connected, ja, ist gut
Ist gut, dann
Disconnect
Und
Connect
So, dann starten wir mal unsere Windows
Recover, sag mal, irgendwie ist das
Windows Logo falsch
Das stimmt irgendwas nicht
Ha
Möchte Windows starten?
Was hat er Probleme hier mit dem Ding?
Ok, wisst ihr was?
Wir restarten mal
What?
What the hell?
Ok, ich hab's aufgegeben
zu verstehen, was Windows teilweise macht
Connecten wir wieder
Ist das auch das Richtige?
Ja
Ok, also
Dann probieren wir das mal aus, mal gucken, ob es in der VM
immer noch nicht erkannt wird
In der VM wird es
immer noch nicht erkannt
Ok
So, nach was muss ich mal ein Disk
M, G, hier, das da, ne?
Ach, der erkennt das jetzt gar nicht, oder was?
Der, Leute, jetzt erkennt
Ah
Monka
Da ist doch irgendwas ganz im Arsch jetzt, oder?
Da ist doch jetzt irgendwas
ganz im Arsch, Leute
Soll ich mal an und aus machen?
Ich mach mal an und aus
Ich mach mal die Festplatte an und aus
Man weiß ja nie
Bleibt das connected?
Ah, ne, jetzt ist weg
Connect to a digital machine
Windows 10
Ich mein, unter Linux hat das Erkennen wenigstens noch funktioniert
Und jetzt?
Muss man hören?
Der knackst?
Ne, jetzt hat er aufgehört zu knacksen
Was ist?
M, G
Ok, ich mach noch mal aus
Ich mach das noch mal aus
Da stimmt doch irgendwas net jetzt
Ok, jetzt gucken wir mal ob das unter
dem Hostsystem wieder erkennt
War da was wichtiges drauf?
Die Gameplays, die hätte ich schon gerne wieder
Die kann man ja
Ok, da erkennt das
komischerweise
Ah, wisst ihr woran das liegen kann, dass der das nicht
richtig erkennt?
Das ist ein USB 3 Gerät
Kann es sein, dass der Problem hat mit USB 3
in der VM?
Wobei, unter Linux ging es auch super
Ich könnte es aber mal in USB 2 stöpseln
Ja, ich hatte schon an die VM gepasst
und da hat es nicht erkannt
Ok, ich starte den Windows Grab noch mal
Der hatte eben schon irgendwelche Probleme
Ansonsten muss ich den Grab auf dem Host installieren
Da hab ich ja gar keinen Bock drauf
Ok, connect, yes
Der erkennt den ja auch, guckt
What the fuck
Fuck
Wow, Alter was
Gerätemanager
Wie macht man den Device Manager überhaupt auf?
Ok, ich glaube ich muss das doch auf dem Host machen
weil das in der VM nicht will
Disk Drives
Oh, der ist voll am rumspacken
Der erkennt das Ding nicht
Ok, Leute, ich mach noch mal aus
und stelle ein, dass ich das auf USB 2 mache
Ich trau das Sache hier gerade nicht
Ok, ich mach noch mal aus
und stelle ein, dass ich das auf USB 2 mache
Ich trau das Sache hier gerade nicht
Options, wo ging das jetzt noch mal?
USB 2
Alter
Man weiß hier, man weiß nicht
Ich könnte auch raw disk passthrough machen
Connect
Fuck
Sucked mal richtig, Alter
Huge suck
Alter, geh weg
Jetzt erkennt das gar nicht
Ok, dann stöpsel ich es mal an
an USB 2 vom Host
War das jetzt erkannt?
Scheiße
Ah, ah, moment, es blinkt, es blinkt
Es blinkt
Guck mal, der greift noch drauf zu
blink blink
Ah
Da ist er
Über USB 2 ging es jetzt witzigerweise
Ok, ich mein, gehen tut die immer noch nicht
By the way, warum steht die nicht hier drinnen?
Mal F5, mal F5 pushen
Windows hat da irgendwelche Schmerzen mit auf jeden Fall
Ok, das will gar nicht
Ich lasse jetzt einfach mal
Also jetzt probieren wir mal die Sachen vom
Nein, geh weg
Und warum gehst du nicht mehr in Fullscreen?
Windows, come on brah
Wir haben es kaputt gemacht, Leute
Kann ich jetzt nicht einfach tausend
Ich mein, hier erkennt er ja
Hier erkennt er es, dass es dran ist
Hier erkennt er ja, hier erkennt er es, dass es dran ist
Vielleicht soll ich nochmal rebooten
Ok, also
Erstmal ein Chrome installieren, weil Edge kann man nicht ernsthaft verwenden
Das ist, ich glaub, ein Kirby Soundtrack
Yes
Auf die Plätze
Chat, macht euch bereit
Wird installiert
Wir wissen ja, dass nach Auf die Plätze automatisch wird installiert kommt
So, also
Edge ist am Start
Windows spackt immer noch rum und hat überhaupt keinen Bock irgendwas zu machen
Disk
M
Vielleicht muss man das einfach nur mal schließen und dann geht's wieder
Also
Also was? Recuva soll ich downloaden?
Das kann es bei Heise irgendwo
Jawoll
Kann man das downloaden?
Moment, nicht Chip, Heise
Heise
Download
Setup
Ok
So und Sebaro, jetzt kannst du nochmal
Was wolltest du vorhin ausprobieren?
C, H, K, Disk
Und dann was?
Wie geht denn das überhaupt?
Ich und Windows Zeug
C, H, K, Disk
Und dann was?
Minus F, Minus R
Was ist Minus F? Ist es Minus Force?
So und wie geht man da jetzt die Platte an?
Einfach so, E, Doppelpunkt?
Oh anscheinend
Das Ding
Das Ding plinkt die ganze Zeit einfach nur
Und macht nichts
Ich glaube ich muss die
Ich glaube ich muss die vowen nochmal
Ich glaube ich muss die vowen nochmal Neustarten
Okay, wenn ich die VM neu starte, dann blinkt die Platte auch nicht mehr.
Was schon mal gut ist, was dafür spricht, dass die Platte richtig an der VM dran hängt.
Jetzt blinkt's wieder.
Vielleicht muss ich es doch über den Host machen.
Okay, das können wir über den Host machen, das können wir über den Host machen.
Scheiß drauf, das will ich ja nicht.
Nee, keine Chance über die, ich will mir das eigentlich nicht installieren auf meinem
Host.
Na gut, okay.
Ah, Moment.
Postchamp, was ist das für ein, das hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Ich glaub nicht, dass die VM Buggy ist, ich glaub die Festplatte Slowed ist halt übelst
down.
Guck mal hier, wie es hängt, Alter.
Okay, nee, ganz vergessen, weißt du was, wir machen seinen Host dran, Disconnect, bam.
Okay, also, dann machen wir jetzt erstmal, was da Sebaro uns mitteilen wollte.
Da ist sie.
Geh Doppelpunkt, ich glaub ich muss die noch mal außen wieder dran machen, hä?
Darf ich in die Eigenschaften jetzt wenigstens rein?
Kommt da noch irgendwas?
Ich denke auch nicht, dass sie erkannt ist, geht.
Okay, das Ding blinkt einfach nur noch wie verrückt, ich glaub ich muss das noch mal
ausmachen und wieder anmachen.
Ich glaub das wird sonst nix.
Ich mach's noch mal aus, zack, und wieder dran.
Ah ja, jetzt hat er's gecheckt, okay nice, connect to host.
Test, das ging nicht, hab ich schon ausprobiert.
Meinst du, Siehbaro, ich soll erstmal nix machen und gucken was passiert.
Leute, die Festplatte blinkt einfach nur noch random und macht gar nix mehr.
Ah, Moment, jetzt, pause champ, pause champ, zumindest hat sie wieder aufgehört zu blinken,
das ist gut, was sie in der VM nicht gemacht hat.
Warum soll ich nicht klicken, wo ist der Unterschied, ob ich klicke oder nicht klicke?
Mal gucken, ob das Fenster jetzt wenigstens aufgeht.
Okay, das funktioniert, also auf dem Host funktioniert die, in der VM funktioniert nicht.
Also wie heißt der Recuva Heise?
Das ist im USB-Dock, aber Internet anschließend bringt auch nix, hab ich schon ausprobiert.
Zum Download.
Sloyskit, glaub ich nicht, dass ich das auf die Reihe krieg, das ist irgendeine Profi-Recovery-Software,
da bin ich wahrscheinlich zu blöd für.
Kann man auch ausprobieren, also okay, jetzt protesten wir erstmal das Ding.
Okay, das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Video, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss, tschüss.
Was?
Ernsthaft?
Mach mal, schick mal ein Video mit Altersbeschränkungen, das will ich ausprobieren.
Machen wir jetzt das nächste Pornhub, einfach 80% des Contents.
Okay, also was ist das hier?
Okay, früher konnte man so machen, embed, fuck, das geht nicht mehr, scheiße, das war
immer der beste Trick.
Ich mein, ich kann's mit der Kreditkarte bestätigen, aber das ist doch der Witz, Alter, was ist
das für ne Scheiße.
Kann man, okay, okay, wir testen jetzt mal was.
Youtube.dl, geht das noch, aha, okay, youtube.dl scheint noch zu gehen, by the way, was ist
das für ein Video, was laden wir uns hier gerade runter?
Kann man das, kann man das, what the fuck, das ist altersrestricted, warum ist das altersrestricted?
Weil's flat fuck friday heißt, oder wie?
Okay, aber man kann's ohne, Leute, man kann's ohne Altersbeschränkung gucken, einfach
youtube.dl, easy, witzig, dass das noch funktioniert.
Okay, jetzt hab ich den, jetzt hab ich den Krempel runtergeladen, extract, so, erstmal
virus ist raus, Leute, warning, okay, gleichmals atmen ran, easy, kein Ding, und jetzt, aha,
deleted files, next, video, in a specific location, ja, e, nee, g, aber g ist ja gar
nicht, aber g ist ja nicht mehr zugreifbar, das funktioniert doch überhaupt nicht, Leute,
was habt ihr mich da wieder für gbaitet, was, 13 Dateien gefunden, 400 files found, what,
das kann überhaupt nicht sein, so viele Dateien sind da gar nicht drauf, cancel, ja, von wegen,
null files found, guck mal, wie der uns verarscht, okay, das funktioniert damit schonmal nicht,
das funktioniert damit nicht, das geht wahrscheinlich nur, wenn ich Dateien gelöscht hab, aber
ntfs noch geht, nee, das ist, das, das bringt's nicht, okay, das war's schonmal nicht, doch
checkdisk, das wird im Leben nicht funktionieren mit checkdisk, Leute, ich kann euch übrigens
beweisen, dass es nicht funktioniert mit checkdisk, das hab ich doch sogar schon ausprobiert,
guck mal, rechtsklick, warte mal, ich zeig dir das, zack, was, Lust, meine Uni-Programmier-Aufgabe
im Stream zu programmieren, komm ich weiter, kannst mich fragen, aber komplett programmieren
werden wir das nicht, testdisk geht nicht, testdisk, sagt, gibt's net, okay, tools, also,
access checkdisk, oder, because windows can't access disk, rib, sebaro, meinst du, es hat
Sinn, wenn ich's jetzt noch mal über die Konsole ausprobier, okay, ich mach das, chk,
dsk, g, Doppelpunkt, minus f, minus r, also sebaro, so, yep, okay, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
hm? yeah, Leute, warten mal ab, das funktioniert ja noch lang nicht, what?
Ja leute warte mal ab das funktioniert ja noch lange nicht
What
Sie war ich glaube nicht dass das funktioniert sind das stunden
Warte einfach mal eben okay es ist leicht wir warten jetzt 285 stunden ist ja kein problem
was passiert eigentlich jetzt wenn ich in explorer reingucke explodiert es dann
der macht guck mal der macht weiter
ich muss mal hören ich muss mal hören ich muss mal hören ob der macht auf der festplatte
der macht absolut gar nix also wenn die stage sieben prozent hat leute und es ist total null
das dauert ja ewig
ndsf fix habe ich schon ausprobiert hat nicht funktioniert
smartwerte keine ahnung bringt mir eh nix ob die nur gut oder schlecht sein händerte ja nichts
dran okay windows windows prozent es geht jetzt doch recht sag ich
by the way warum ist warum ist das warum ist total null kommen danach noch mehr stages
kommen das sind meine video files das sind meine da sind meine video files ja klein blablabla
dvr keine windows soll ich mal nicht runter scrollen
okay die zeit geht aber recht schnell runter was passiert wenn man jetzt abricht
hat jemand eine idee was passiert wenn man jetzt abricht
dann löscht sich das im baro
die musik guck mal die musik die willst du jetzt richtig wissen
die musik die musik die musik repeat
die musik die musik die musik die musik die musik
die musik die musik die musik choreography
Okay
Ja leute wir könnten wir könnten
Wir könnten prall wir könnten preis jam
weitermachen in der Zwischenzeit
Snee abonniert Twitch Prime Dankeschön
Exzellent für den Exzellent Subscription Dankeschön für den Sub
Aber guck mal das geht jetzt wieder langsamer
Also ich habe meine ich habe eine frage an euch
Kennt ihr mal eine gute analytics plattform die nicht google analytics ist
Ein google analytics ist ja matomo kennisch das ist das was früher pivik war das ist zum selbstausten
vielleicht was nicht selbst gehostet das
Pertham was ist das dann
analytics analytics geht ab hast du schon ci cd für preis jam aufgesetzt nö
habe ich nicht
können wir eigentlich ein bisschen drum basteln scheinheit scheinheit klingt nach
gachi buzzer wieso nicht einfach kugel weil ich die leute nicht mit google
tracken will ich will die leute gar nicht tracken mit irgendeinem service
ehrlich gesagt am liebsten am ja dann müsste ich aber eigentlich selbst
hausten die google ich weiß nicht ich das problem bei google ist du brauchst
für alles in google account ich will das nicht mit meinem google account machen
oder dann bräuchte müssen wir in andere google account machen
am liebsten eigentlich aws stats
was ist das simple privacy focused web analytics ok
das hat schon mal gutes logo das gefällt mir was willst du sehen analytics naja
was ist das seiten aufrufe unic visitors vielleicht noch die plattform von wo die
aufrufen länder so die üblichen sachen halte
das finde ich cool das gefällt mir
get started for free get started for free klingt gut was kostet
standardmäßig stonks.org sagt bloß die seite gibt er das kostet ja immer
direkt was aber selbst hausten kostet nix
wie kann man
do not latest extract zip archive
ganz ehrlich wenn es selbst haustet ist clicky was ist clicky clicky analytics
ganz ehrlich wenn es selbst haustet ist dann wäre es am liebsten ich könnte
einfach einen container starten und einen javascript snippet einbinden und gut
ist plausible iow
simple and privacy friendly alternative to google analytics pricing
ich finde es doof dass das alles geld kostet warum geben die mir das nicht einfach kostenlos
never sub never donated neighbors wi-fi free entertainment warum kostet das was
selbst hausen no gs based analytics oder sieht schon mal stylisch aus live demo
admin jawoll ok das finde ich schon mal cool ja no data super
aber das wird mir ja eigentlich schon reichen
eigentlich wird mir das schon reichen sowas in der richtung und wie ist das
andere noch mal das war früher was früher pivik war
ops what the fuck pivik
matomo genau github wie installiert man das selbst
ist das mit abstand das beliebteste ok was kann das so alles anzeigen oder schon
cool war das schon nice guck mal da kann ich da kann ich richtig krasse track
action machen gibt es einen docker container von probieren
jetzt mal aus
nice das probieren wir das probieren wir jetzt mal ich meine während der kram in
die festplatte recovert 33 prozent schon was herkommt mir heute wie
recover meine festplatte war wisst ihr was mich echt stutzig macht das total
bei einem prozent steht ich habe schon ich habe für den ich habe für den
preisschamp schon prometheus statistik eingebaut geht später um einige stelle
was man hoffen sonst wird das heute abend nichts mehr
ne ne es ist usb 3 wieder usb 3 und am haus angeschlossen was macht er da
eigentlich ich meine in der zeit kann er doch die komplette festplatte quasi
befüllen ich glaube elf stunden soll das soll das heißen
auslastung nix juckt ihr nicht und disk ok disk ist ausgelastet
oder warum warum wieder mit 235 mb kann der überhaupt kann die platte überhaupt
zu viel ist eine magnetplatte die flutscht aber die flutscht also leute ich
will vielleicht noch mal noch mal zurück zu dieser zu ich lass mal die
außen zu zu der zu der tracking geschichte also das sieht mir schon ein
bisschen overkill aus ehrlich gesagt was gibt es als docker container zum selbst
hausen tracking also unique user und solche geschichten was nicht so extrem
oversized ist auf der anderen seite ich meine warum nicht warum nicht auch das
braucht eine eigene datenbank und alles ok fersam ok das da cloudflare ja aber
ich leite es nicht über cloudflare
sample fast google analytics alternative ok zeige ich mal zeige
ich mal hier live demo ja das ist cool das wird mir vollkommen ausreichen also
current visitors ja genau so was hier wunderbar price check doch alternate ja
so was wird mir schon reichen so und was war das andere das hier
page views kann ich in fersam auch sehen ob mobile devices und so was ja ok ich
installe mir einfach mal den docker container und guck mir das mal an also
wie funktioniert das jetzt
download docker running mega delay einstatt oder ok wir probieren das mal
aus während meine festplatte recovert oh leute 2 prozent es geht aufwärts ok
docker run 80 80 habe ich das frei müsste ich frei haben
ok und läuft das jetzt docker ps jawoll da ist es localhost 80 80 wahrscheinlich
starte das kratz noch also angeblich ist es nicht so ist es da
ja doch richtig
bestattet bestimmt noch ein neustand ja ach das ist java
jecker ok was docker locks
Ah!
Nee.
Ist eigentlich okay.
Der F ist das der Dings, ne, also, Followed.
Das juckt dir nicht?
Hm.
Okay, wisst ihr was, ich hab ne Idee.
Manchmal spinnt das Netzwerk Setup.
Was für eine Erste oder Terminal ist das?
Das ist, ähm, ich, ich geh mal davon aus, das war jetzt hier grad Reboot.
Du meinste?
Das ist Manjaro mit E3 WM als, äh, Window Manager oder als, als, nee, nee, ja.
Als, in Anführungsgründen Desktop.
Ah, Linux passend?
Okay, excellent.
Temple OS, ey, der Temple OS Typ, der hatte schon richtig nen Knall, ne?
Ach, Moment, das hat sich jetzt ja geändert, ah.
Ich sollte vielleicht einfach dem Ding nen Namen geben.
Ah, jetzt geht's, easy, guckt's euch an.
Jetzt geht's.
Einfach mal neu gestartet, gut ist.
Okay, your side, ähm.
Local Hosts.
50-50, nee, 5000.
Ah, ja, das ist ja nice.
Das muss man einfach nur ne Snippet hinzufügen oder, alter, was ist das für Java Script Magic?
MonkaS?
Nicht Java, Java Script?
By the way, das kann doch so gar nicht funktionieren mit dem Tracker, oder?
Das kann doch mit dem, mit dem Tracker überhaupt nicht funktionieren.
Weil in dem Tracker steht doch nirgendwo Local Host 80-80 drinne und wenn da nicht Local Host 80-80 drinne, wie soll der das denn da einschicken?
Meint ihr, das geht?
Ach hier, hier setzt er das zusammen, oder was?
What the fuck, alter?
What is happening?
Genau, es sieht für mich aus, als würde es einen Local Host Tracker schicken, aber Local Host Tracker.js gibt's ja nicht.
Was, okay, was, was, was ist, wenn da POC drin steht?
Okay, das hat damit überhaupt schon aber gar nichts zu tun.
Wird schon gehen, wir testen es jetzt einfach mal.
Ist das geschrieben, Mojut Block zu dodgen? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Okay, Update, zack.
Okay, und jetzt?
Ah ja.
Okay, ich probier das jetzt einfach aus, ich, ich edit das jetzt und dann gucken wir, ob's funktioniert.
Und in der Zwischenzeit ist meine Festplatte gefixt.
Oh, 66% Leute.
Excellent, jetzt gibt, jetzt gibt er alles.
Depots, Preischamp, pullen wir einmal, Git, Remote, Update, Git, ich resette das jetzt einfach mal, reset, minus, minus, hard, origin, faster.
Damn.
Probieren wir das mal aus und dann mach ich's auf Preischamp.
Was macht der Server eigentlich in, in dem du immer umbaust?
Hä?
In welchem Server baue ich immer um?
Verstehe ich, das, das war, ist mir zu, zu big-brain gerade, verstehe ich wirklich nicht.
Komm mal, 70%, mal gucken, wie schnell es da geht.
Ja, Sibaro war eben ab und schon noch 70%.
Ach, der Hetzner Server.
Der Hetzner Server hostet das hier, Moment, beta.preischamp.org.
Das hostet der Hetzner Server.
Da siehst du live, welche Jobs gerade zu welchem Preis was zur Verfügung haben.
Deswegen hat er auch so viel Auslastung, weil er im Hintergrund die ganzen Seiten crawlen muss.
So, okay, jetzt probieren wir das mal.
Also, was hat der gesagt? Ich soll einfach diesen Kram hier in meinen JavaScript pasten.
Das klappt doch im Leben nicht. Wollt ihr mich veräbbeln?
Das glaube ich erst, wenn ich es sehe.
Ach so, jetzt sind wir auf localhost port 8081, okay.
Connection refused.
Weil?
Wow.
Ich verwende das falsche.NET Framework, um es zu starten, okay.
Okay, noch mal.
Okay, der Preischamp ist am Start.
So, und jetzt, ich soll das jetzt einfach da rein, okay, index.html, einfach reinhauen.
Bam.
Dahin oder da oben in header?
In header, ich gebe dir header, Alter.
Siehst du, ich wusste, dass das nicht geht.
Das Snippet ist einfach fail.
Da muss ich localhost 8080 reinschreiben, dann geht es wahrscheinlich.
Guck, bam, jetzt funktioniert es nämlich auch.
So, jetzt habe ich die Seite aufgerufen und sehe ich jetzt im Trecker was.
Ein current visitor.
Geht das jetzt? War das vorher auch schon eins?
Zwei, das funktioniert.
Aber warum steht da Null, obwohl es da oben zwei sind?
Warum steht hier nichts drin?
Ich glaube, die sind im Trecker nicht drin, kann mal kurz gucken.
Aber die haben die 3060 noch nicht drin.
Da muss ich erst warten, bis sie das geupdatet haben, dann kann ich nichts machen.
Und wie heißt das andere, Delphitec?
Nope, ist nicht drinne. Kann ich noch nicht hinzufügen.
Hat irgendjemand einen Plan, warum das hier nicht anzeigt?
Das ist lokale SQLite.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn der leeft.
Ah, jetzt. Okay, der braucht einfach ein bisschen.
Das ist ja cool. Mehr brauche ich ja gar nicht.
Und wo sieht man jetzt nach Browser und so?
Oder kann der das nicht?
Dafür brauchst du Pro?
Ach, das ist nur bei Pro.
Okay, dann probieren wir noch mal den anderen aus.
Das war ja easy. Das war jetzt sehr easy zu installieren.
Okay. Mal Tomo Docker.
Probieren wir das.
Kann es kein SQLite verwenden? Nee.
Moment, wie hieß das andere Ding nochmal?
Docker.
Okay, die haben eh einen Postgres drin.
Platte rettet sich gerade.
Hoffe ich mal.
Oh Leute, der ist durch.
Aber der braucht da so ewig für...
Fuck, der meint das ernst mit elf Stunden.
Meint der wirklich, das dauert echt elf Stunden?
Okay Leute, ich sage euch, was wir machen.
Okay, im Stream mache ich aus.
Und dann gucken wir, ob die Platte funktioniert.
Sebaro, du kennst dich damit doch aus.
Kann man diesen Check nicht machen, ohne dass der hier irgendwie
Free Clusters checkt? Bin ich da abgerechnet?
Okay, wir machen jetzt erstmal weiter.
Kann es SQLite?
Okay, dann installieren wir jetzt das hier.
Docker.
Haben die einen Compose?
Example.
Examples Folder.
Ach da.
Dann probieren wir das mal damit.
Beim Ryzen wurde ein...
Das ist normal, der hat keine Currency Informationen dabei.
Okay, dann machen wir es so.
Ich breche das ab.
Und eine halbe Stunde bevor ich off gehe,
und lasse es nochmal ohne Slash R laufen.
Keine No Risk No Fun.
Aber Leute mal ernsthaft, das kann beim Abbrechen nicht kaputt gehen.
Das kann beim Abbrechen nicht kaputt gehen.
Warum sollte das beim Abbrechen kaputt gehen?
Der muss das Ding noch in einem halbwegs konsistenten Zustand haben.
Ich installiere jetzt erstmal das andere Tracking und dann gucke ich mal.
Was kostet eigentlich das andere?
Pricing.
Das fand ich eigentlich gut.
Das war richtig easy.
Guck mal, der hat die User getracked und gut war es.
Alles klar, alles gut.
Das kann man nicht selbst hosten, die Pro Variante.
Dann machen wir jetzt mal das hier.
Stalker Compose.
Zack, haben wir hier einen TMP Ordner oder sowas?
Ja, was auch immer für Zeug drin ist.
Beste Ordner Benamung aller Zeiten.
Wer sich übrigens wundert, warum Wim immer so komisch pastet mit Einrückung.
Guck mal, Set-Paste.
Wenn ich das ohne Set-Paste mache, dann macht es in dem Fall auch richtig.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich einen Plugin drin habe, was das macht.
Aber dann spackt es manchmal rum.
Also, MySQL Passwort.
Wer braucht MySQL Passwort?
Das ist komplett overrated.
Mal gucken, ob denen Ihr Example einfach so geht.
Docker Compose ab.
Ach so, das stimmt.
Das musste man Docker Minus Compose mit Namen nehmen.
DB Enf.
Und was soll da so rein?
Ah, hier.
Alles klar.
Easy.
Oh, die Conf hätte ich vielleicht noch nehmen sollen.
Waiting.
Postchamp.
So, was macht meine Festplatte?
Okay, Leute, ich riskiere das jetzt.
Ich spreche jetzt ab.
So, passen Sie die Modus an?
Doch, ich spreche ab, Chat.
Chat, ich spreche jetzt ab.
Doch.
Ich spreche jetzt wirklich ab.
Bam, abgebrochen.
Das bricht gar nicht ab.
Warum?
Ich habe Steuerung C gehämmert.
Okay, okay.
Cancel CRK Disk.
How to safely stop?
Wenn die Antwort ist, es geht nicht.
Restart.
Task Kill.
Okay, easy.
Easy.
CRK Disk.
Bam.
So.
Leute.
Die Festplatte geht wieder.
Easy.
Sebaro MVP heute wieder.
Ich gucke mal, ob die Daten wieder da sind.
Sieht so aus.
So, was sagt er jetzt, wenn er hier sagt, reparieren?
Eben hat er doch gesagt.
Okay, okay, vielleicht ist er jetzt ein bisschen schneller.
Vielleicht ist er jetzt schneller, wenn ich jetzt hier sage.
Tools Error Checking.
Vielleicht ist er mit der Windows Variante schnell, aber unter der Haube ist es auch Check Disk, oder?
Hättest du auch schon vor 15 Minuten machen können.
Ja, der Chat ist natürlich wie immer schlauer.
Wie das war es jetzt?
Wie das?
Ernsthaft?
Warum wollte er dann vorher etwas 20 Stunden machen?
Macht doch mal CRK Disk GF.
Ja, es ist repariert.
Richtige Hacker Mans wieder heute am Start hier.
No problemo.
Hyper Clap.
Ja, das ist ja geil.
Funktioniert.
Der Rekord.
Nee, funktioniert alles cool.
Das ist ja nice.
Oh.
Port ist also Docker Stop.
Und jetzt bitte back ab was jetzt geht es ja wieder.
Was?
Das ist ja schon wieder cancer Setup hier.
Das nervt mich schon wieder, dass es so kompliziert gemacht ist.
Am Sudo.
Okay, läuft.
Okay, warum?
Okay, machen wir, machen wir.
Eins, zwei, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs.
Ist das und das hier das gleiche Passwort?
Nee, das ist glaube ich was anderes.
Okay, ab.
Okay.
Macht der jetzt was?
Das sieht schon mal besser aus.
Das ist immer.
Matomo ist a free Librile Web Easy Steps.
Alles klar.
Oh, PAP.
Okay, wie hieß dieses andere Ding nochmal?
Ist das als Docker?
Das fand ich dann nämlich auch ganz gut aus.
Und danach in der Cloud installieren.
Easy.
Pause.
Okay, die wollen Postgres haben.
Also Donald bla bla bla.
Jaja.
Ich glaube, localhost block der Enix.
Next.
Localhost block der Enix.
DB, DB, DB.
Passwort hatten wir keins vergeben.
Doch.
War das Passwort dafür?
Nee, das ist nicht gut.
Warte, Moment, da muss man mal nachgucken.
Das stand doch hier.
Steht doch gar kein Passwort drin.
Leeres Passwort.
Ja.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Genau, Firefox, helf uns.
Geht nicht.
Excellent.
Okay, habe ich jetzt irgendwie Mist gemacht?
Kann man das mit Route machen?
Easy.
Gut, geht immer.
Next.
By the way, diese Config ist mega...
Das ist übelst cancer hier.
Ach, das ist der Nginx-Config.
Jetzt habe ich es kapiert.
Okay.
Passwort, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Was sonst?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Email, nein.
Next.
Email.
Website name.
Localhost 8081.
Timezone Berlin.
Nee, Germany.
Okay, es gibt kein Berlin und es gibt...
Boah, das ist ja der ekligste Date-Time-Picker,
den ich lange gesehen habe.
E-Commerce, not E-Commerce, mir machen keine E-Commerce.
Traffic, alles klar, kommt rein.
Next.
Congratulations, continue.
Oh.
Ah, Moment.
Das habe ich verkackt.
Ah, shit.
Kann ich da nochmal zurück ins Setup?
Okay, das muss ich nochmal machen.
Ich hätte 8080 angeben müssen.
Okay.
Das Hupen, das ist die Musik.
Ach, warte mal, da hat die Container jetzt gar nicht gelöscht.
Wie war denn das?
Minus...
Minus V, okay.
So, mal der Chat.
Bei mir ist der einzige Chat, die sich gegenseitig helfen
und wo auch echt ab und zu mal was Sinnvolles rauskommt.
Das ist so richtig keck weight, wenn man das mit den restlichen Twitch-Chats vergleicht.
Okay, next, next, next, next.
Root, hat er mal gesagt, 123456.
Yes.
123456, 123456.
keckw at pricechamp.org.
Next.
Website name.
Cute Analytics.
http://localhost.8080
Der wollte wissen, was der bekommt.
Select City, okay.
Dann müssen wir jetzt für diesen komischen Date-Time-Picker hier machen.
Der ist wirklich schlecht.
Wenn ich Date-Time-Picker, was habe ich denn? Location-Picker.
So, e-commerce not an e-commerce site.
Tracker, jawoll.
Oh, die Url ist falsch, das ist die Docker-Url.
Also man muss ja sagen, sonderlich Big Brain ist das alles nicht, ne.
Das ist die Docker-IP, kann ja nicht funktionieren.
Auf der einen Seite muss ich die Seite eintragen.
Und jetzt trägt er hier mal eine Docker-IP ein.
keckwait.
Vielleicht kann man, das kann man, kann ich auch von Hand anpassen.
Go-Access.io
Warte mal, ich mache Visual-Web, okay, klingt gut.
Ne, das reicht nicht.
Das reicht, das reicht nicht.
Ich will Unique-Besucher auswerten und sowas.
Was?
Das glaubt ihr doch selbst nicht.
Warum soll ich was drauf geben, wenn einer do not done, okay wir sind Netz.
Was?
Ich hab das doch vorhin geändert?
Hä?
Das ist konfiguriert, das ist, wollt ihr mich verappeln?
Natürlich, das ist nicht konfiguriert, das hab ich doch vorhin geändert?
Jetzt hab ich aber mit Port 80, okay, also was soll ich machen?
Pivic-Config-Config-inni-php
Wie, du hast das, du hast, doch ich hab das geändert.
Ich hab Local Host, doch Chat, jetzt erzählt ihr mir Mist, ich hab doch 80 80 eingetragen.
He doesn't know, he lacks critical information.
So.
Passt auf Chat.
Da?
Hier, seht ihr es?
Ist doch vollkommen richtig.
Genau da muss man es eintragen.
Ach Moment.
Das ist das für die Webseite.
Ja aber wo kann ich das dann einstellen für die, wo kann ich das dann einstellen für das Ding selbst?
Also wenn einer im Chat noch schreibt, ich sag seit 5 Minuten, das steht doch da, dann gibt es ein Timeout.
Geht mir nicht auf den Keks.
Kek wait.
So, aber wo kann man das einstellen über das Webinterface?
Das ist doch bescheuert, wenn es nicht über das Webinterface geht.
Das da beknackt.
Wo steht es?
Ich sehe es, ne das ist die Webseite, die man tracken will.
Ok, das sackt.
Ok, da gehen wir in die Config.
Ne, das ist die Nginx Config.
Ich hab ja gar keine Config hier auf dem Filesystem liegen.
Ich glaub nicht, dass es in der Nginx Config eintragen muss.
Oder?
Hier.
Also ich muss, ich müsste in die, ich müsste in die PivotConf, in den Container Exact.
Alter ist das bescheuert gemacht.
Ernsthaft Leute, was haben die sich denn dabei überlegt?
Was haben die sich denn dabei ausgedacht?
Ich weiß wie das funktioniert.
Halt auf zu Backseiten, heute ist ja ganz schlimm.
Ich bräuchte so, ich bräuchte so ein Erziehungs-E-Mode.
Was ist denn heute los?
Aber, ne das ist, also das Setup, das hätte man schon einfacher machen können, wenn man
da schon ein Compose-Example anbietet.
Warte mal, die hatten doch hier englern.
Das heißt, in ihr Example funktioniert nicht, sehe ich das richtig.
Ah, gucke mal da, guck mal da, was ist denn das?
Ne, Moment, Import-Script.
Ne, das wird ja was anderes.
Muss ich jetzt, ich muss jetzt wirklich in den Container und dort die Config anpassen?
Das ist aber bescheuert.
Das gefällt mir vom Setup her an, das könnte man schon da machen.
Ja anscheinend, echt so.
Was natürlich cool wäre, wenn der mir die Config-Dateien außerhalb schreiben würde,
macht er aber nicht.
Denkt die, ja wahrscheinlich.
Aber, wobei, den ihr Beispiel ist ja, den ihr Beispiel ist doch selber 8080.
Das ist ja den ihre Docker-Compose.
Okay, also was muss ich eintragen?
Zeig her.
After making too many...
Wie ging das so, ne?
Oder war es nur i?
Wir brauchen den da.
Ne, aber war das it danach oder davor?
Ah, ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Ne, warte mal, ging das nicht, dass ich da hinten noch bin bash oder so?
Ne, das war aber was anderes, ne?
Ne, ne, du darfst das nicht schreiben.
Doch bin bash war das, genau.
Excellent.
Gibt's nicht, also sh?
Jawoll.
Also wo muss ich hin?
Etc.
Tja, die Frage ist, wo liegt der Kram überhaupt?
Wo liegt denn der Shit?
Stimmt user share oder irgendwie sowas?
Tja, wo könnte...
Feind?
Ist ein Feind drauf?
Oh, immerhin.
Was, der Ordner, wo du warst?
Da?
Ne, oder?
Ach, da ist das drinnen?
Ach, okay.
Alter, con.
So, und jetzt muss ich hin.
Die Datei gibt's doch überhaupt nicht, die der mir hier anzeigt.
Config, config any php.
Okay, general.
Hier, da.
Trusted Hosts.
So.
Okay, löschen wir das andere.
Bam.
So, aber jetzt muss ich wahrscheinlich reloaden, dass das funktioniert.
Okay.
Easy, live reload.
Alles klar.
Richtig easy.
Nice, easy as fuck.
So, guck mal, jetzt hat er auch localhost 8080 drinne.
Das ist schon mal gut, alles klar.
Okay, JavaScript Tracking Code.
No data has been recorded, alles klar.
Dann machen wir diesen Müll mal weg.
Machen den anderen Müll rein.
Oh, welcome.
Da gibt's das, da gibt's das Cute Analytics Grill, Grill, Grill.
So, also was kann man sich da jetzt angucken?
Das Matomo Grill ist das.
Guck mal, das ist so ein Chebat Video.
Du klickst drauf, du klickst drauf und bam, es geht nicht.
Alles klar, sehr gut.
Also, was sieht man da jetzt so?
Wizards over time.
Nicht so ganz, das ist localhost.
Das verstehe ich, dass er den nicht anzeigen kann auf der Weltkarte.
Aber wusstet ihr, dass localhost aus den USA kommt?
Das war mir auch neu.
Konnte ich so noch nicht zuordnen.
All website, tech manager.
Okay, das ist übelst komplex, aber das finde ich schon mal ganz nice.
So, und jetzt kann ich mir angucken, users, overview.
Ich sehe einen Unique Visitor.
Wir können noch mal einen Unique Visitor machen.
Wir machen nämlich einfach mal hier noch mal auf und da noch mal auf und keine Ahnung.
Hier noch mal ein Ding auf.
Jetzt haben wir drei, drei Unique Visitors.
Aktualisiert sich das von allein?
Ist der so schlau und checkt das?
Obwohl das...
Guck mal, warum habe ich jetzt nicht noch einen Unique Visitor bekommen?
IOS?
Okay, alles klar.
Ist der so clever und checkt, dass es der gleiche Browser war?
Das ist clever.
Okay, probieren wir das mal hier von aus.
Was habe ich für ein IP?
Alter.
Das da, 2, 1, 3, 1.
Ich hoffe, das lauscht.
80, 81, jawoll.
Moment, was mache ich denn da?
Wollte ich ja von außerhalb machen.
Jawoll, geht.
Okay, da geht jetzt die Aufrufe nicht, weil das ist Development Mode.
Development Load geht Local Host.
Aber er sollte schon mal einen Visitor erkannt haben.
Oder auch nicht.
Echt, Duplock hat es geplockt?
Nö.
Doch.
Also angeblich hat es was geplockt, aber es zeigt nicht an, dass es was plockt.
Ach hier.
Okay, oder?
Wie kann man das?
Ich mache das jetzt einfach mal aus.
Stimmt, ich habe No Tracking respektiert.
Der hat garantiert No Tracking gesetzt.
Okay, das können wir jetzt nicht machen.
Der ist zu schlau.
Wo stellt man denn jetzt um?
Ich will No Tracking nicht.
Geh mal weg.
Boah, kann das viel Zeug, Alter.
Wo kann man umstellen, dass der das ignorieren soll?
Das ist mir fast schon ein bisschen viel.
Ich probiere noch mal das andere.
Komm, Scheiß drauf.
Das geht doch schnell.
Hier haben wir noch mal Docker Compose.
Easy.
Tracker-Url ist Local Host.
Ach stimmt.
Ja klar, dann kann das doch nicht funktionieren.
Stimmt, das kann nicht funktionieren.
Das geht nur hier.
Und hier erkennt er es.
Wahrscheinlich von der IP.
Aber es funktioniert, das sieht man ja auch.
Ich finde es ganz interessant, dass er denkt, dass es iOS gewesen ist.
Aber Firefox in der VM kann nicht funktionieren, weil der Tracker auf Local Host ist.
So, also, das finde ich schon mal ganz nice.
Bauen wir gleich mal in den Preis-Champ ein, Hackermans.
By the way, IPs sehe ich nicht, oder?
Ich will nämlich gar keine IPs haben.
Absender-IP will ich nicht, ich will die anonymisiert haben, ich will die gar nicht sehen.
Ich will keine IPs speichern, sonst muss ich auch noch Cookies einbauen und Gedöns.
Seht ihr irgendwo die IP, die hoffentlich nicht vorhandene IP?
Letztes Octet fehlt hier, aber wo steht sie denn überhaupt?
Ach hier!
Ok, das hinten fehlt, alles klar.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Ok, das ist richtig, richtig krass Business-Enterprise-Shit.
Dann machen wir den mal wieder aus.
Lassen wir den mal, wir haben heute Big-Prain-Time für Ordner-Namen.
Machen wir das andere noch mal.
Machen wir das andere noch mal, gucken wir mal, ob wir da irgendwas anpassen müssen.
Ja ok, Postgres, Database, replace me with a random string, das ist mir random genug.
Ok, ich glaube hier müssen wir nichts anpassen.
Compose, up, bam.
Ich will halt gucken, wie die Verteilung ist.
Also sprich lohnt sich das zum Beispiel, dass ich iOS irgendwie was übers Knie breche,
weil der Scheiß funktioniert halt auf iOS nicht.
Fathom hieß das irgendwie so.
Ok, localhost 3000, da ist es, bam.
Can't reach database, but why?
Hatte die DB nicht ein Exit? Ah, tatsächlich.
Wait, was hat die DB für ein Problem?
I couldn't read from the input file, it's a directory.
Hä?
Was ist das?
MonkaS, was macht das da?
Ok.
Es ist doch nicht so einfach, wie ich gedacht hab.
Compose.
Ha, lull.
Die haben mich gebaitet, das funktioniert gar nicht.
Wisst ihr was wir machen? Können wir clone das Repo? Und dann mach ich das nochmal, so wie die gesagt haben.
Wenn man jetzt down, alles weg damit, jawoll.
Jetzt soll ich was, ich hab das Repo geklont und jetzt soll ich was einfach nur Docker Compose up.
Ok.
Docker Setup funktioniert nicht, da hab ich ja schon wieder richtig Bock drauf jetzt.
Ready for startup?
Nee.
Jetzt läuft er, oder? Jetzt läuft er.
Hä?
Es war doch?
Hab ich doch richtig geschrieben? Ach nee, das ist ja gar nicht der Default User.
Ja gut, was ist der Default User?
Default User?
Das hab ich... Ach, Admin. Warum steht da standardmäßig... Alter, ist das ne Cheap...
Die müssen an Kacknoop User denken. Du kannst doch nicht das Vorausfüllen mit was, was es gar nicht gibt.
You don't have any websites, go to settings, jawoll.
By the way, das ist der falsche Desktop, so war mal, das haben vier Dings und hier kommt da Chrome hin, wo ich auf Local Host gehe.
So. Add Website, Domain.
Local Host 8081.
Enable share-Uhr, was auch immer das heißt. Ach so, vielleicht, dass mehrere Sachen auf einer Uhr laufen.
Das könnte natürlich sein. So, also Local Host 8081.
Jawoll. Und jetzt?
Okay, und wie adde ich jetzt den Tracker? Kackweight? Gibt's da nicht irgendeinen Button für? Ah, Darksteam.
Die sind schon mal gut, die sind schon mal nice. Ja.
Oh, guck mal, der Tracking-Code, der kann auch kurz und knackig sein.
Also, dann fügen wir das mal hinzu. Der Müll kommt raus.
Jawoll. Vielleicht gucken, ob's geladen hat. Jawoll, hat funktioniert.
Ach, das wegen iOS, Leute. Das wegen iOS, weil ich's auf iPhone und Dings anstehen hatte vorhin.
Nice. Guck mal, der erkennt's. Easy.
Ja, das ist top für mich. Das ist genau das. Guck mal, das ist easy. Das ist genau das. Das reicht mir.
Das ist genau der Funktionsumfang, den ich brauch.
Das ist genau der Funktionsumfang, den ich brauch. Ich seh' Operating System, ich seh' Devices, ich seh' Views, Visitors.
Was ist denn eine Bounce-Rate? Wie oft die refreshen oder was? Active Sessions?
Ja, das ist nice.
Gibt's noch mehr so Dinger? Ich suche jetzt mal so nach einer Liste. Was gibt's da?
Also, was haben wir? Matomo?
So, dann gucken wir Self-Hosted. Mal in diese Self-Hosted-Liste auf, Dings.
Das steht da gar nicht drin.
Das steht da alles gar nicht drin. Analytics. Awesome Analytics, okay.
Okay, das steht da drin. Shinet.
Okay, das ist eigentlich geil. Aber das, ohne Mist, das find ich cool. Das ist genau das, was ich brauch.
Das ist easy as fuck aufzusetzen.
Okay, schauen wir mal, was die anderen Sachen noch...
Steht da auch dieses Smart-Smart-Dings. Das hat echt einen Crap-Namen, dieses Matomo. Das kann ich mir nicht merken.
Aber hier ist General Analytics. Okay, da gibt's ja Milliarden von...
Offen. Freshlytics.
Schauen wir mal, was die ganzen anderen Sachen auf GitHub da haben. Der Goat-Counter.
Das hat vorhin schon mal einen vorgeschlagen. Das fand ich auch cool.
Aber im Prinzip ist es ja mehr oder weniger alles das Gleiche, ne?
Die haben fast gleich viel, außer das Ding hier. Die haben fast gleich viele Sterne.
Das hat 5400 und das andere hat Dings. Haben die den Docker?
Docker-Fall. Läuft das mit dem Ex... Läuft das mit dem SQLite?
Ne, die wollen Postgres. Ja, dann ist egal. Dann kann ich das auch so lassen.
Benötigt das jetzt ein Cookie-Hinweis? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Bald kommt noch das DSGVO-Banner. Ich sag's euch.
Doctor Go, plausible. Was haben die miteinander zu tun? Docker. Also, wie installiert man's?
Keck, keck, wait.
Das installieren wir jetzt auch noch. Scheiß drauf. Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus.
Wie gesagt, das mit der Festplatte hat ja auch so ganz gut Funktion. Hast du Impressum drauf?
Weil die Seiten sind nicht mal live. Ich verdiene damit nichts.
Ich trag da einfach meinen Vater ein ins Impressum.
Der hat mich schon oft genug gescampt, dann kann der auch mal da drinstehen.
Okay, Docker-Compose-Setup. Ja, noch mehr, bitte. Noch mehr Zeug.
plausible-events-db. Alter, was starten die da wieder alle für 30 Milliarden Dinger?
Ich meine, im Docker-Composer ist ja alles easy. Da können wir das mal ausbringen.
Add required configuration. Okay, das ist ziemlich einfach. Das probieren wir jetzt auch noch mal aus.
Machen die da mit U-Limits? Hab ich jetzt nicht gesehen.
Also. Tja. Das ist nur, wenn du davon ausgehst, dass mein Vater noch so heißt.
Oh, warum ist es jetzt kaputt? Ach, Moment, das war das alte ja noch.
Nur, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass mein Vater so heißt wie ich mit Nachname.
Der Goat-Counter. Auch nicht schlecht.
Guck hier, da seh ich die Goats, die visiten. Das sieht aber echt aus wie 1995.
So, ich test jetzt plausible nochmal. Also was war das mit DuckDuckGo und plausible?
Hab ich jetzt gar nicht gecheckt.
Ach so, Docker hab durchsuchte. Ah, verstehe, verstehe.
Okay, also git clone, holen wir das mal aus. Das machen wir wieder zu.
Das fände ich aber gut. Das gefällt mir besser als das andere, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Und jetzt müssen wir was? Config anpassen.
Und was mach ich damit jetzt? Ach so, das muss ich da eintragen.
Wo eintragen? 5?
Hosting? Oh, was? Plausible. Plausibleconf.
Secret Key?
Wie wärs, wenn die mal reinschreiben, was man damit macht?
Okay, Base-Uhr ist Local Hosts.
Jetzt die Frage, auf was läuft denn das standardmäßig?
Auf was läuft das standardmäßig? Port.
8000, dann ist meine Uhrl.
Passwort, 123456, User, E-Mail, Admin, Replace me ist gut.
Secret Key, 123456, wozu soll ich dann Secret Key?
So, ab, ich will zugucken.
Okay, SMTP, der Pult ist erstmal das halbe Internet.
Hosting, GeoIP.
Ich glaub, dafür miet ich mir echt so ein 2,90 Euro Server noch.
Das kann er ja mitmachen.
Ich brauch ja so ein Ding im Internet, sonst könnt ihr das ja nicht abrufen.
Übrigens, ich hab auch schon geguckt, wie man Prometheus Analytics einbaut in den Preischamp.
Da muss ich dann gucken, was die App so macht in meinem Dashboard daheim.
Trackingpreischamp.org, das könnten wir eigentlich machen, wenn ihr wollt.
Wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit, wir könnten das noch... Nee, mach ich nicht, mach ich nicht jetzt.
Kannst du das nicht auf dem gleichen Server packen?
Doch, aber eigentlich, doch könnte ich machen.
Weil, ich muss da eh einen Docker draufhauen, weil ich will den Preischamp, also die Datenbank, äh, nicht die Datenbank, was laber ich denn?
Die das Crawling in Docker-Container packen, dass ich die CPUs besser regulieren kann.
Warum hat der so hohen Traffic?
Weil der 190 Chromium-Instanz im Hintergrund hat.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob's geht, aber es scheint zu funktionieren, also sagen wir,
Localhost, Port 8000. Oh, Kegwaid.
Tja, das Docker-Setup funktioniert wohl doch nicht so richtig.
Und warum nicht? Und warum nicht?
Und warum nicht? Warum geht's nicht?
Address family force, I'm not supported. Hä?
Was will der von mir?
Okay, Crap-Setup, funktioniert nicht.
Ich hab nicht genug Zeit, mich mit Müll rumzuschlagen, was nicht funktioniert. Kann's doch so gut sein.
Die sollten den Kram insofern aktuell halten, dass das, äh, zumindest das ausprobiertes Setup funktioniert.
Vielleicht war auch das, ich wollt grad sagen, dass das Secret-Key...
Ähm, genau. Dann hab ich nix gesagt.
Dann machen wir den Secret-Key so. Hab ich schon gelöscht?
Okay, ab.
Gucken, ob's jetzt funktioniert.
Das sieht schon anders aus, aber auch nicht.
Aha.
Okay, successful. Successful sieht schon mal besser aus.
Ah.
Aha.
Oh nee, das hab ich nicht geändert, oder?
Mist, ich hab vergessen, was hab ich da reingeschrieben.
So was hab ich schon da reingeschrieben.
Äh.
Replace me, okay.
Toll.
Och.
Ah.
Die machen einem das Leben auch schwer, oder? Die machen einem echt das Leben schwer.
Okay, also noch mal.
Dann heißt es cutechatataiaya.org. So, sehr gut.
Weil ich nehm mal nix, was es geben kann.
Weischem.org. Nicht, dass der noch rumspammt.
Okay, jetzt aber.
Ab.
Drei Temp-Ordner.
Wenn du meinst, das sind die einzigen Temp-Ordner, die ich hab, dann hast du dich geschnitten.
Bei mir liegen wahrscheinlich noch 60 weitere Temp-Ordner irgendwo rum.
Aber am besten ist immer noch meine Visual Studio Projekte, die ich hier in der Windows guck mal an.
Console App 15, 14, Web Application 2, Web Application 11, WinForms App 11.
Ab und zu mal sinnlose Namen, wo ich heute nicht mehr weiß, was es ist.
Console App 11. Wunderbar.
Wir haben einen auf der Arbeit, der nennt seinen Ordner immer Hans.
Weiß ja auch nicht warum. Seine Temp-Ordner.
So, jetzt.
Jetzt, da sind wir am Start.
Okay, das finde ich optisch schon mal äußerst nice gemacht. Settings.
Nicht überladen, add a website.
Okay, localhost 8081, wollen wir tracken.
Add.
Guck mal, es geht auch kürzer.
Waiting for first page view.
Okay, der Crap kommt raus.
Wenn der Chat so weitermacht, nenne ich meine Filenames irgendwann so Ruby.
Oh, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Unknown Host, warum?
Oh, was ist das?
Ignoring Event.
Okay, ich vermute, ich habe irgendwas falsch generiert.
Hab ich irgendwas falsch gemacht?
Ignoring Event.
Domain.
Ist doch richtig.
Da stand extra ohne HTTP und WWW. Ja, ja, genau.
Funktioniert ja schon mal sehr gut.
Woran könnte das jetzt liegen, dass der da...
Könnte es an der Konfig liegen?
Ja, das könnte sein, dass ich die Url verkackt habe in der...
Dass man hier Base-Url sagen muss, ja, das kann wirklich sein.
HTTP, Doppelpunkt, Doppelslash, dass man sowas hier machen muss.
Dass der jetzt denkt, dass er das...
Irgendwie, ja, das könnte sein.
Alles weg damit, noch mal ab.
Es wäre auch gut, wenn er einfach gesagt hätte, Konflikt passt nicht oder so, ne?
Hallo?
Will es markieren?
Okay, noch mal das Ganze. Ja, ja, das gibt's nicht, ich weiß.
Wait.
Warum bin ich authentifiziert auf einmal?
Ich hab das gelöscht und neu gestartet.
Was wird hier gemacht? Ich such grad, wie ich Unic Seiten aufrufe zählen kann,
da ich weiß, wie viele Leute die Seite benutzen. Selber Secret Key, ah ja, das wird sein, genau.
Okay.
Localhost 8081, nippet.
Ah, das sieht schon besser aus jetzt.
Start collecting.
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt geht.
Ne, Ignoring Event. Warum?
Geht das vielleicht nicht lokal?
Tja, gut, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
127.0.0.1 für Trick 17.
Ignoring Event on localhosts.
Ha, nein, fuck. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte gebaited.
Hey, because, ne, das sollte schon alles richtig konfiguriert sein.
Okay Leute, legit, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Delete my account, nein, nein, nein.
Kann ich die Seite löschen?
Ja, das kann sein, dass der localhost plausible.
Das kann sein, dass der das ignoriert. Hier, guck mal, Configuration Options.
Ne.
Die zeigen das sogar.
Was? Allow testing?
Na gut, das ist ja kein Ding. Das ist ja kein Ding. Dann tragen wir einfach die IP ein.
131.
Hier.
80.80.
Haben wir nochmal aus.
Weiß gar nicht, ob man das immer jedes Mal neu machen muss, aber.
Dann machen wir es hier mit der IP, ist auch in Ordnung. Kann ich auch mitleben.
So, ähm.
Gehen wir da hin und gucken mal, was da auf 80.80 ist. Noch nix.
Immer noch nix.
Ach ne, nicht 80.80. 8000. Oh ne, hab ich 80.80 eingetragen. Ich kack noob.
8000s. Aber, aber erreichbar sollte es eigentlich sein. Ah ja, da ist es.
Hab ich, hab ich da eben, hab ich jetzt 80.80 oder? Oh, ich kack, guck mal, ich dab, alter.
Oh, Monka V. Ne, Monka V hab ich nicht aktiviert. Geht gar nicht. So, ab.
Ja, aber Webseiten IP kann ich ja auch die hier nehmen. Ich hab jetzt mal alles geändert.
So, das sieht schon besser aus.
So, und dann tragen wir nämlich gleich schon mal den richtigen Kram in Webseite und gucken, ob es dann endlich getrackt wird.
Auf, komm, komm ab.
Postchamp.
Da sind wir.
Jawoll. Add Webseite. Das da.
Tja, mit Port, ohne Port. Machen wir mit Port.
Ja, müsste, müsste, müsste eigentlich schon. Okay, exquisite. Auf geht's. Jetzt aber.
Was? Wie, ich, du, du kannst doch gar nicht wissen, dass? Na doch, weiß er wahrscheinlich.
Okay, dann. Ups.
What? Moment, was ist das?
Kann das sein, weil der hier auf der Seite drauf ist?
Ah. Die Aufruhr, die alte, die Uhr ist das hier oben die Mann. Guck mal, da sind wir.
Krasse Track Horse.
Visitor am Start.
So, gehen wir mal von der anderen Kiste drauf. Ups.
Kann ich gerade nicht Copy Pasten aus der Vm raus?
81.
Page Views. Das checkt er nicht, weil er die Seite nicht geladen bekommt, glaube ich.
So, also wunderbar.
Das gefällt mir fast noch besser als das andere. Was sehen wir denn hier? Desktop Tablets.
Countries kann man nicht feststellen.
Schauen wir mal, was er macht.
Wenn immer ein Kognitor aufmachen.
Ups, ich sollte vielleicht aber das Richtige nehmen.
Unique Visitors. Okay, das checkt er.
Das andere an einem Dark Theme, das hier vielleicht auch. Oh, ne.
Ohne Dark Theme.
Dark Theme ist live, haben sie geschrieben.
Aber bestimmt nur bei denen Hosted.
Bestimmt nur bei denen Hosted.
Guck mal, das Lokal ist wohl ziemlich alt.
Seht man hier die Version?
So eine Versionsanzeige wäre schon mal ganz nett. Einfach, was man hat.
Verschen.
Gibt es da gerade mal einen Monat, kann er nicht auf Docker sein.
Aber ich meine, eigentlich hätten sie das schon GitHub pushen können.
Okay, das ist cool. Das ist so minimalistisch. Und es ist eigentlich alles drin, was ich haben will.
Ja, was war denn jetzt schicker?
Das da?
Ach so, das haben wir gar nicht mal laufen.
Das hatte denn Dark Theme.
Ja, aber das finde ich gut. Das gefällt mir. Das ist richtig schön simpel.
Und ganz ehrlich, mehr muss das auch gar nicht können.
Einfach Webseite.
Unique visitors total page. Was ist denn der Bounce Rate?
Sind es die Leute, die wieder abhauen?
Ah, ja gut, ich habe ja auch direkt wieder refreshed.
Haben die schon eine neuere Version?
Ah nee, danach gibt es nichts. Man könnte den Master direkt nehmen.
Aber das wird er nicht.
Das kann man wahrscheinlich im Compose nicht angeben, oder?
Die werden keinen Master Container haben. Nee, es ist schon Latest.
Doch, gehabt.
Okay, die haben prinzipiell nur Latest.
Ist aber ganz nice.
Ganz ehrlich, wisst ihr, was mir am liebsten wäre?
So etwas ganz Simples, was am besten eine Single Go Executable mit SQLite Datenbank.
Ich meine, für meine eine Seite da.
Nee, aber das ist nice. Das gefällt mir. Ich glaube, das nehme ich.
Ich glaube, das nehme ich. Das ist wirklich ziemlich, ziemlich easy.
Okay, die wollen das, was den Docker macht. Hatten die hier noch irgendwie was drauf?
Ah, WSomme Analytics.
Der Posthog. Ich probiere jetzt nicht mehr aus, aber.
Ich gucke mir das morgen mal in Ruhe an.
Oh, die haben drei Spiele. Ich gucke mir morgen mal in Ruhe an, was ich da nehme.
Go, gibt es irgendwas?
Parsley.
Diese Listen sind leider nicht einheitlich.
Druid. Das ist irgendein Apache Projekt, glaube ich. Das ist aber ganz was anderes.
Das ist auch was anderes.
Kann das, kann das ASP, diese Standard ASP.NET Logging?
Jetzt wird es ganz, ganz cool.
Very minimalistic.
Okay, das hat mir zu wenig User. Das ist tatsächlich zu minimalistisch.
Oder hatte ich ein anderes Repo? Nee, das.
Ich bin ja mittlerweile anspruchsvoll. Ich will, ich will dann auch, dass sie gleich Screenshots und ein Demo auf der Seite haben und sowas.
Das ist was anderes. Das ist irgendwas anderes. Alter, jetzt gehen wir nicht auf den Sack.
Perfekt weiter.
Null W. Siehst du? Kommt gleich weg, gleich weg, gleich weg. Alles weg. Auch weg. Shinet. Gibt es noch? Was war Shinet? Screenshots.
Geht es eigentlich auch ganz praktisch aus. Compose braucht es auch eine Datenbank.
Dann kann ich auch dabei bleiben. Gut, Leute, das, das wird es hier. Parsley. Easy.
Das werde ich verwenden. Da kann ich nämlich gucken, wie viele Leute Preischamps so verwenden.
Ich meine, wisst ihr, die einfachste Variante wäre eigentlich.
Ich baue in die, ich baue in die Seite einfach am Anfang einen Postrequest ein, der einfach eine User ID an mein Backend schickt.
Und ich zähle das im Hintergrund. Fertig. Das wäre die einfachste Variante.
Da bräuchte ich das ganze Analytics Zeugs dann. Aber das wäre wahrscheinlich zu einfach.
Also irgendwie, dass man irgendwie eine User ID oder sonst was generiert random.
Sagt mal, ist das denke ich jetzt zu einfach? Könnte ich nicht einfach sowas machen? Jetzt mal wirklich.
So, also das hier ist ja meine App. Meine App Start. So und ich könnte doch einfach sagen.
Vielleicht denke ich das mir jetzt auch zu einfach. Ich könnte einfach sagen, Local Storage.
Get checken, ob es hier irgendwie keine Ahnung ein Item gibt mit dem Key Preischamp ID oder irgendwie sowas.
Wenn es das nicht gibt, dann sage ich Local Storage Set Item Preischamp ID.
Vielleicht denke ich es auch zu einfach. Gen, Unique, keine Ahnung, Unique ID. So, für jeden User eine andere ID.
Und dann mache ich einfach einmal einen Fetch und schicke das an mein Backend.
Und dann habe ich doch Unique User eigentlich, oder? Bin ich jetzt zu ppega?
Warum brauche ich überhaupt ein Analysetool? Jemand Böswilliges.
Ja gut, aber im schlimmsten Fall generiert er halt Fake Seiten Statistik.
Who cares? Soll er machen, wenn er Spaß dran hat.
Ja, das stimmt. Und vor allem die machen wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen sinnvollere Checks mit IP und sonst was.
Ja, okay. Aber jetzt mal Frage an euch. Was hat euch von diesen Tools am besten gefallen?
Also das hier Fathom fällt raus. Das hattest du in der Pro Version.
Was so schlecht an dem Analysetool ist. Naja, ich muss eine extra Domain machen.
Die dann im Zweifelsfall von irgendwelchen Adplocker noch geplockt wird oder so.
Du fandest umarmi nice. Warum? Warum fandet ihr umarmi besser als Dings hier als? Ja.
Warum fandet ihr es besser als? Ich habe vergessen Pro plausible nur wegen dem Dark Mode.
Wegen dem Setup. Oh, das stimmt. Das Setup war einfach. Das Setup war wirklich einfach.
Ich meine, wir können es ja noch mal kurz starten.
Hat das jetzt gelöscht? No website configured. Okay. Go to settings and website, localhost, domain, zack.
Ja, das stimmt. Das war schon. Das war schon ziemlich easy, muss man muss man sagen.
Da kannst du eigentlich nicht viel verkehrt machen. So und jetzt das das jetzt hier rein.
Jetzt, wo ihr es sagt. Ja, eigentlich ist das vom Setup her schon angenehm gewesen.
Das war es. Easy. Und schon haben wir analytics.
Sibaro, was postest du da wieder für Dinger?
Ich trau mich jetzt nicht im Stream aufzumachen. Genau, das ist doch eigentlich top, oder?
Hinter mein Web Server und gut ist. Ist safe. Ja, ich habe es am zweiten Monitor schon aufgemacht.
Und es steht alles drin, was man braucht. Und es hat einen Dark Seam. Also mehr kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht wollen.
Aber mal gucken, was man da. Github, Github, Github. Genau, konnte man das auch so installieren ohne Docker?
Ach, guck mal, das ist auch so. Ach, man muss hätten die, wenn das jetzt noch mit SQ lite wäre, wäre das easy.
Was für ein Ding auf Discord oder was? Oder wo? Gucken wir mal.
By the way, was passiert, wenn man auf etwas 18 channels drückt, während man während man streamt, geht es dann auf?
Das probiere ich jetzt nicht. Nein, also im Stream Modus geht es nicht auf.
Ok, also zeigt mal her. Warte mal allgemein. Was gibt es? Pet. Das ist gut, das gefällt mir.
Das ist nice. Kann man eigentlich in Discord die Schriften irgendwie größer machen? Erscheinungsbild?
Ich bin doch alt. Ist das jetzt größer? Ist das jetzt wirklich größer?
Ja, ist größer, ist größer. Doch die Emojis werden auch ein bisschen größer. Und wie macht man das, dass Gwida jetzt größer?
Ach nee, man kann auch einfach, ich kann es auch einfach so lassen.
Oh, exellent. Genau das Richtige für mich. Genau das Richtige für mich. Zoom-Stufe, jawoll.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Ja, dann nehme ich das, dann werde ich den Preis-Champ wohl hier mit tracken.
Was natürlich richtig cool wäre, wenn ich es schaffen würde, das irgendwie von der gleichen Domain ausliefern zu lassen, aber das klappt wahrscheinlich nicht gescheit.
Ich meine, ich brauche ein neues Subdomain oder einen anderen Port, eins von beiden. Dann wird es wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Aber dann wird es wahrscheinlich wieder Adblock. Jaja klar, ich kann ein Subdomain machen, aber dann ist es eine andere Url.
So Eats ist das gar nicht, das kommt auf die Anwendung an.
Jaja, ich habe ja eine Reverse-Proxy davor, aber dir bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig. Normalerweise entweder ein Subdomain zu machen oder den Port zu ändern.
Oder aber irgendwelche Urlumschreibe-Magic, so nach dem Motto beta-preis-champ.org-analytics geht dann darauf oder so.
Was aber die jeweilige Anwendung checken muss.
Mein Tool sagt, das ist verfügbar.
Der da?
Ja, ist doch verfügbar. Im Februar halt.
Ne, das macht der Crawler halt, aber was soll ich tun ja.
Echt ist das so?
Subdomains werden nicht ge-
Sicher?
Keg Waits? Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Ist das echt so?
Weil du kannst ja zum Beispiel auch nicht so ohne weiteres von
Localhost 8080 auf Localhost 5000 zugreifen. Ist ja auch die gleiche Domain anderer Port halt.
Da bin ich mir echt nicht so sicher.
Ich mein wir könnten das mal ausprobieren. Aber vielleicht nicht jetzt.
Aber das Docker Setup gefällt mir, das ist schon einfach. Das dumme ist nur, ich hab hier kein Docker drauf.
Eigentlich wollte ich auch darauf verzichten, ein Docker drauf zu machen.
Na, wenn ich mich da auf die Kiste verbinde.
Ich hab glaub ich kein Docker drauf. Und eigentlich wollte ich auch darauf verzichten, den drauf zu machen.
Weil der mit IP-Tables so viel gefunnelt macht im Hintergrund.
Youblock block man Matome auf einer Subdomain. Ihr hätt mich jetzt auch gewundert, wenn das was anderes wäre.
Vielleicht kann man irgendwie wirklich Magic machen.
Welches Tool ist das? Das ist, oh ich weiß nicht, war das N-Load oder B-Dingsbums-Monitor?
Äh, by the way. Sind die Hacker? Oh, Leute.
Die Cloud Commodores sind wieder da.
Was hat denn Hetzner für Probleme? Kann mir das mal irgend einer erklären?
Ich mein, das kann doch nicht sein, dass das regelmäßig nicht erreichbar ist.
Das geht gleich wieder. Das geht gleich wieder. Das hatten wir letztens schon mal.
Haust du doch auf Azure? Ja, dann kostet es aber halt mehr.
Jetzt ist ganz, Leute, jetzt ist ganz RIP. Jetzt ist ganz vorbei.
Jetzt ist der Preis-Cham tot, Leute. Der Preis-Cham ist, äh.
Der Preis-Cham sollte eigentlich nicht gehen. Ach, das habe ich noch im Cash. Nee, der Preis-Cham ist weg.
Also so, so gebe ich da kein Geld aus, Hetzner. Die haben gerade eine Störung.
Ja, aber, also ich meine, wir hatten jetzt, wir haben jetzt wie viel?
Drei Tage gestreamt und dann zwei Tagen hatten wir Störungen? Was soll ich nicht öffnen?
Nee, das war heute Morgen. Das ist was anderes.
Jetzt ist er wieder da. Guckt, das liegt nicht an meinem Sauber. Das liegt an Hetzner. Das kann es aber echt nicht sein.
Das hatten wir jetzt öfters abends schon. Da bin ich gar nicht begeistert von.
Das sage ich euch ganz ehrlich. Das ist doch, das ist doch nicht normal.
Wir hatten das gestern oder vorgestern schon mal.
Wie geht es der Festplatte? Die geht wieder.
Was wäre denn das Streams überladen? Nee, das hat doch mit dem Stream nichts. Guck, jetzt geht es wieder. Jetzt geht es wieder.
Das Russen Squad ist fertig hacken. Guck, geht wieder alles.
Sag mal, wurde der wirklich gedetost oder sowas? Guck mal, hier incoming. Volle Pulle. Guck mal den Load an.
Hat er, hat er wirklich, hat er wirklich irgendwie einer?
Hat er ernsthaft? Oh, von KS.
Da hat es jetzt erst gecheckt, dass ich Endings eingegeben habe.
Ist da ernsthaft jemand? Nee, das glaube ich nicht, oder?
Es wird doch nicht ernsthaft jemand so einen Mist dedosten, oder?
Ich gucke gleich mal ins Log. Cloudflare.
Aber, Alter, das wäre echt pains. Aber witziger, witzig. Ich gucke mal, was bei Hetzner die... Was kostet Cloudflare? Ich habe Cloudflare nie verwendet. Das ist standardmäßig sogar kostenlos.
Ah, geht wieder. Ist der Dedos nicht so ganz, nicht so ganz durchgängig.
Feltuban für... Nee, ich habe, ich habe jetzt nicht gedacht. Aha, aha. Was ist hier los?
Ich habe jetzt nicht gedacht, dass da irgendeiner das so geil findet, den Preischamp zu dedosten. Was war minus T für Time? Nee, da sieht man nichts.
Das sieht, also das ist... Naja, wobei. Naja, nee, guck mal. Alle sechs Sekunden, das macht dem nichts.
Ach guck mal, es ist wieder, es ist wieder weg. So Leute, ich logg mich jetzt mal bei Hetzner ein und gucke mal den...
Auslog, ja, kann ich gleich gucken. Ich logg mich mal kurz bei Hetzner ein und gucke mir mal den Netzwerk Graph an.
Ihr könnt auch einen TCP-Dat machen, der ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Es könnte aber auch sein, dass das der Server selbst ist oder so, dass die...
Dass der irgendwas garbage collectet oder so, aber des Notzeugs wird es nicht sein. Oh Mist, ich habe mich vertippt, fuck.
Alter, jetzt kann ich mich nicht einloggen. Okay, scheiß drauf, ich machs auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Der lasst dann ungefähr 10 CPU-Kerne aus, aber das wird es nicht sein.
Okay, ich guck mal in den Netzwerk Graph. Cloud.
Okay. Was sind da, was sind da? Network PPS. Package per second sind das, oder? Ja. Okay.
Das Ding macht einfach mal 80.000 Packages per second. Wird das zugespammt.
Kegweight. Na geil. Und von wem? Ja, das seh ich nicht. Das seh ich vielleicht, wenn ich Glück habe.
Vielleicht seh ich das, wenn ich Glück habe, nochmal im Log.
Eventuell die Preise cashen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, das hat damit nichts zu tun. Das hat damit nichts zu tun. Okay. Wir können mal ein IP... Ach wobei, scheiß drauf. Was können wir gucken? Warlog.
Nö, das bin ich. Aber der wird halt massiv gespammt. Der wird halt massiv gespammt mit 80.000 Packages pro second.
IP liegt. MonkaS. Der immer schlimmer.
Die UfW auf Drop oder Recheck? Das ist eine gute Frage. Wo kommt man das nochmal sehen? Status Default.
Default Deny. Tja, was ist, was, was, was macht Deny? UfW Drop Reject.
Ah, okay, also kann ich da UfW Default. Default Reject.
Oder Deny. Ist Deny Drop? Ja, ist okay, passt doch eigentlich. Ich mein, die schönere Variante ist eigentlich Reject.
Dann kriegst du eine Fehlermeldung zurück, aber in dem Fall ist Drop ja eigentlich das Richtige.
Der müsste sagen, welche an und wieviel Traffic. Ey, wie gesagt, ich sehe es ja, dass es 80.000 Pakete sind.
Tja, vielleicht mach ich da wirklich noch was drauf auf der anderen Seite. Erstmal nicht akut.
Was halt witzig ist, dass es immer nur während dem Stream ist. Es gibt keine Hetzner Firewall davor.
Man könnte ein Hetzter Loadbalancing davor machen. Und beim Paket der Patrick hat recht.
Fehlermeldung bringt mir gar nichts, wenn er einfach nur Pakete spammt.
Wenn er versucht, irgendwo drauf zuzugreifen, irgendwie SSH, sonst wie.
Aber Hetzter Cloud ist doch eigentlich steht aus Geschütz. Naja, was sollen die machen?
Also ich sehe es auf jeden Fall im. In den Crafts, ja.
Dass ich doch per Telegram, warum, dass da irgendwie einer mein SSH knackt, habe ich keine Angst.
Warum ist heute der RAM Verbrauch so hoch? Naja, weil er erst freigibt, wenn er fragt.
So, ich gehe mal Hetzner Crafts.
Haha, witzig. Leute, wir hatten gerade 150.000 Packages per Second.
Und jetzt gerade, ach ne, das war vorher schon, das war vor einer Stunde.
Ja, lustig.
Ansonsten nie was.
Ich meine, es juckt mich ja noch nicht mal groß, weil ich halt einfach Cloudflare davor und gut ist.
Na gut.
Jetzt weiß doch jeder die echte IP.
Du weißt auch die echte IP, wenn du die. Du weißt auch die echte IP, wenn du die Domain auflöst.
Ich habe aber das Gefühl da ist noch mehr im Argen hier.
Ja, mit Cloudflare davor ist es was anderes, das war jetzt ja aber gerade nicht Thema.
Na gut, dann packe ich halt einen Cloudflare davor.
Alles klar, ich muss jetzt ins Bett. Der Preischamp läuft ja noch weiter.
Guck mal wie viel Traffic ich verbraucht habe insgesamt.
Nix, der Incoming ist ja komplett umsonst.
Alles klar Leute, ich gehe ins Bett, wir sehen uns, bis morgen, machts gut, see you.